hello everyone welcome to the september
2022 ask me anything edition of the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
and coincidentally the day that this ama
podcast gets released into the wild
which will be monday august 29 is the
first day that i will be teaching at
johns hopkins so very excited about this
at 10 30 a.m the physics of democracy
will meet and then on wednesday i'll be
teaching that class again as well as
topics in the philosophy of physics so
very exciting also very tedious in some
ways like i have to worry about learning
how to use canvas which is what the
universities these days use as their app
that interfaces between professors and
students and stuff like that
nobody likes cannabis as far as i can
tell but there it is everyone's got to
use it uh i got to figure out you know
the room that we're in remember all that
that i needed to worry about back many
years ago i got to worry about it again
i looked at the rooms that we're in and
they're okay but they're not perfect and
i have to decide whether or not
to try to make them more perfect very
very exciting there's also substantive
things about democracy in physics and
philosophy that i need to worry about
that's the fun part very much looking
forward to that very much looking
forward to meeting the students and uh
getting excited about what they're
interested in and how we can learn about
it during the upcoming semester but also
you know thinking about students and
teaching them has reminded me of what
it's like to be a student all the issues
there and that's part of why we have the
mindscape big picture scholarship so let
me give you a very brief update on that
remember this is a scholarship that will
give ten thousand dollars to someone who
wants to study the fundamental mysteries
of the universe as an undergraduate
college slash university student with
some preference for first generation
students uh people who are from
underrepresented groups within physics
philosophy biology computer science
whatever the area is that they are going
to be studying and what is the good news
is we have enough donations from the
mindscape listenership to fund a
scholarship this year so someone is
going to get it so i also wanted to send
the word out there to potential students
that you should apply if you are going
to be a college undergraduate this
upcoming year
i've already gotten requests from people
who are not going to quite be that
no it's got to be people who are going
to be college undergraduates this year i
mean maybe you're entering maybe you're
already there but that's who it's for uh
so you go to bold.org
scholarships
mindscape and check it out um also if
you are not going to be a college
undergraduate but you want to contribute
to the scholarship you can certainly
still do that um we have enough to fund
one scholarship we're hoping to get
enough to fund another one so we're just
a couple thousand dollars away from
being able to fund two scholarships this
year if we don't make it no big deal
that money will roll over and we'll use
it next year so feel free to either
donate or spread the word to people who
might want to do that either as
applicants or as donors bold.org
scholarships
mindscape
occasional reminder this is the ask me
anything edition of mindscape which
means it is funded by patreon supporters
i feel like i'm just asking for money
all the time here that's not any good
but uh on patreon you can go to
patreon.com
sean m carroll to become a patreon
supporter of mindscape for a dollar per
episode or something like that whatever
you want to donate those are the folks
who get to ask questions every month and
it is through those donations that we
can afford to get the transcripts things
like that and send these amas out into
the world but hopefully everyone enjoys
listening to the questions and the
answers whether or not you are a patreon
supporter the amas are for everyone just
like the rest of mindscape so with that
let's go
[Music]
liam mccarty says what is complexity i
love this question i mean it's a famous
question right
we've been debating the definition of
complexity for decades now and
there's two things that i will say
neither one of which will directly
answer the question liam puts a little
smiley face after his question so i
think that he knows that he's trying to
stir the pot a little bit here the one
thing i will say is that i don't think
there is a single definition of
complexity i think that there are
aspects of complexity that are important
one aspect is there's sort of structure
going on on various different scales
another aspect is that there's some
number of steps that it takes for a
process to happen yet another aspect is
that the configuration or the image of
something is hard to capture in a short
definition and so forth there's many
different aspects and these are related
to each other but they're not the same
it's very analogous i think to the
discussion we had about the nature of
life with stuart bartlett on the podcast
some time ago and stuart and his
collaborator
proposed
that rather than trying to write down
the definition of life
we would write down all of the different
aspects that we took seriously when we
talk about life right metabolism
reproduction and so forth and we can
even imagine that there are different
things out there that you may or may not
want to call life but that they have
some subset of the different aspects
that life has and that's very
interesting because it helps us plan out
what to look for i think complexity is
the same way like rather than saying
this is what complexity is that is not
what complexity is let's appreciate the
different aspects and put them into
context
but the other thing i will say is that
if i were forced to come up with a
definition i would do it sort of
negatively i would define complexity in
terms of what it is not and but this is
i will admit before i say it very much
thinking like a physicist here as
someone who has interests in computer
science or something like that might
have a very different
way of thinking about complexity but my
definition is the following
in physics we have situations where
sometimes you have a small number of
moving parts right where you're just
doing the planets moving around the sun
or the hydrogen atom or even you know
the uranium atom doesn't have that many
moving parts you know double digit
numbers of moving parts and therefore
it's helpful and useful and possible to
look at the system in terms of just
specifying what every part is doing okay
and that's sort of the simple side of
physics then there's another aspect
where you have many many many moving
parts like gas in a box okay and if you
were back in the 1800s and you were
helping to invent statistical mechanics
and fluid mechanics and things like that
you would realize that you can average
over
the properties of these different tiny
little pieces uh atoms molecules etc to
define collective variables like
temperature and pressure and velocity
and so forth and then in terms of these
collective variables emergent variables
you might want to say uh you get a
different description
that is nonetheless simple right fluid
mechanics and thermodynamics are still
simple in their own ways because the
individual idiosyncrasies of the
constituents don't matter they can be
averaged over smoothed out so that's a
different kind of simplicity in
collective behavior
so you can define complexity and i think
in a in a fairly useful way by saying
it's when neither of those two things
happen
when you neither have just a small
number of particles nor do you have a
large number for which all the
individual idiosyncrasies smooth out and
can be averaged over still giving you
something interesting in complex systems
you have a large number of things going
on and the individual things still
matter in some sense
what exactly that sense is is difficult
to pinpoint but that's what makes the
system complex because you know it gives
rise to unpredictability or at least
maybe at the best statistical
predictability and things like that it
gives rise to you know power law
behaviors rather than a naive
application of the central limit theorem
or something it's not like all
quantities home in on some average but
rather you have a distribution that is
non-trivial and spread out so that's
where complexity comes in where neither
of those two versions of simplicity are
working everything that falls into the
the not fitting bucket then gets called
complexity
christian
wigand or vgond says regarding episode
168 with the neil seth what do you think
is the most promising helpful
interesting fun approach towards a
formal definition of weak emergence
for example dynamical independence as
proposed by barnett and seth or
something like a ratio of macroscopic
and microscopic systems complexities or
some notion of computational
irreducibility
so i don't think it's any of those to be
honest i mean i think that uh what we
talked about with the neil seth is a
version of emergence that is very useful
but it's very much in the particular
context of
you know these stochastic unpredictable
systems right where information uh about
the state of the system or what the
system is going to do can be correlated
from moment to moment and that's very
helpful in those in those situations but
i think you might want a definition of
emergence that is broader than that
certainly the paradigm that i have in
mind is pretty clear but i will confess
that the details are not completely
clear at least to me i think one of the
things i would like to do is to offer up
to the world yet another definition of
emergence that is as broad as possible
and so to me that the definition is just
that
there exists some macro theory that is
to say some theory
which is a way of talking about let's
say the dynamics of the system or
something like that
um that gives some predictions for how
the system evolves and those predictions
are reliable even if they are sometimes
probabilistic in nature flipping a coin
50 50 chance it's heads or tails that's
a theory of the coin even though it
doesn't tell you deterministically what
the coin is going to do okay
and so the existence of emergence is
when you have such a macro description
that is a useful theory
that's it and a macro description of
course is one where
many
particular configurations of the
microscopic system get mapped onto a
single macroscopic description so you're
throwing away some information
that's the existence of what daniel
dennett would call a real pattern if you
go back to the podcast we did with dan
dennett we talked about real patterns
existing hidden in the full
comprehensive description of the system
so if you think once again about fluid
mechanics okay what do you think what
you're saying is that you don't need to
know
where all the atoms are what all their
momenta are to say something interesting
and true about the system there is an
extra pattern over and above
the comprehensive pattern the
comprehensive pattern is given all the
atoms and molecules they obey newton's
laws or whatever if you're doing quantum
mechanics etc but there's an extra
pattern there's a pattern over and above
that a real pattern that says you don't
need to know all the information that
newton's laws need you can throw away
almost all the information if you throw
away the right information okay and so
there is one way of thinking about it
the most naive way is there is a
commuting diagram
maybe this is not exactly the most naive
way this is how mathematicians think
about it okay so there's a diagram uh in
the space of
configurations of the system and the
theories describing the system so you
have the initial configuration of the
system and there's an an arrow that
points you to the later configuration of
the system so the system evolves for
some time but then there's another arrow
pointing off in a perpendicular
direction that says i coarse grain my
system i map that microstate of the
system to a macro state that it's in and
then i can do a third arrow that maps
the macro state forward in time under
the new theory and a fourth arrow that
takes the
evolved microstate to the evolved macro
state so i start from the microstate and
i can either evolve it forward in time
and then coarse grain it or i can coarse
grain it and then evolve it forward in
time and the point is that the diagram
commutes you get to the same place by
either one of those two roots coarse
graining commutes with
time evolution okay i think that's the
most important aspect of emergence and
but there's a lot of details there that
i'm glossing over to make it sound more
clear than it is but i think that's the
heart of the matter
and
one reason why the
topic is confusing is because
what i'm increasingly realizing is that
well i mean it's perfectly obvious the
word emergence means different things to
different people even when you try to
define it they're going to insist on
using their own definition and that's
fine
but
what i what i'm realizing is that there
are some people who have definitions of
emergence that by construction leave out
all of the examples that we understand
so they only want emergence to count
when it's mysterious right or when it
when it's something that is hard to
actually write down the equations for
etc my all of my um inclinations going
the other way that if we have a
definition we should look for one that
works for both
simple situations and for complicated
situations because then our
understanding of the simple situations
will help us gain insight about the
complex ones that we don't fully
understand so anyway i think it's work
in progress to be honest people have
given very good um definitions the
original there's a classic paper by mark
badao about weak emergence and the
difference between strong immersions
that is well worth reading and has many
many citations it's a pretty good
definition if you want that
his definition is basically i could put
it on a computer right which i think is
the same as uh my commuting diagram
macro state definition but there's
little details that do end up mattering
maggie liu says how important do you
think intelligence is for a career in
physics
this is a bit of a loaded question i
mean the simple question the simple
answer is it does matter it's pretty
important um but there are much more
nuanced and sophisticated answers here
because
uh two things number one i don't think
that intelligence is a single thing that
is easy to pinpoint or define and number
two there are many many ways to have a
successful career in physics involving
different skills different skill sets
different career trajectories and the
whole bit being uh an atomic physics
experimentalist is a very different
lifestyle than being a string theorist
it requires very different skills okay
of course in both cases you need skills
but i think that a lot of people you
know
oversimplify the definition of
intelligence and they sort of mix it up
with
some particular aspect of intelligence
that is related to solving complicated
math puzzles
and
that is actually pretty highly
correlated with your success as a string
theorist or other kinds of theoretical
physics but it's not perfectly
correlated i mean within the fields that
i know very well of theoretical physics
some people are much better at math than
others and it's not a perfect
correlation with how good you are at the
physics side of things uh some people
have physical insight that is pretty
amazing you know albert einstein uh was
not as good at math as henri poncare but
he did better at understanding
relativity because his physical insight
was completely unmatched so i i think
that i actually just want to ignore the
question i want to say who cares how
important intelligence is what matters
is are you good at doing physics that's
what matters for a career in physics and
there are many different ways of being
good at doing physics
preston justice says emmanuel kant said
in his critique of pure reason
that whatever the process in the means
may be by which knowledge refers to its
objects
intuition is that through which it
refers to them immediately and at which
all thought aims as a means but
intuition takes place only in so far as
objects are given to us in what ways do
you think kant's description of
intuition would change if he knew
everything we knew about the physical
world today also how would you describe
intuition
you know i i admire emmanuel kant as a
brilliant philosopher a very important
guy um but i'm not very conscient in my
own ways of thinking about these things
and sentences like this are part of the
reason why when kant says intuition
takes place only in so far as objects
are given to us
i'm not sure what he means i mean i
think that he probably has something
very clear in his head but what does it
mean for an object to be given to us
does that mean that it's as i look at it
and sort of experience the coffee mug
right in front of me right now or is it
sort of some a priori notion of extent
in space or something like that i really
don't know exactly what he's referring
to maybe a kant scholar would know
because they're more familiar with his
linguistic stylings than i am but anyway
um
i i think that
again i'm not a con scholar so maybe
this is wrong but i think that
kant also takes intuition much more
seriously and fixedly than i would i'm
someone who believes in intuition but i
don't believe that intuition is just
something that appears instantly when
we're born and never changes i think
that intuitions can be developed i mean
certainly i mean i think in fact it's
kind of hilariously obvious that
intuitions can be developed in some
sense whenever you play a sport whenever
you do any physical activity you notice
that you sort of get better at it in
ways that are not amenable to being
described in words or or put into
cognitive terms you this in your body
right how to hit the baseball or how to
hammer the nail or whatever it is how to
cook a meal how to drive to work you
know there's a whole bunch of things
that we do in the world that are system
one as daniel kahneman would say not
system two the conscious cognitive part
of our brains and we can train that we
can get better at it and there's a
version of that in
science where you get to know
the scientific insights better whether
it's relativity or quantum mechanics or
dna or biology or whatever and you
develop an intuition for it so i don't
think that it you know i don't know what
it means it doesn't seem very helpful to
me to say intuition takes place only in
so far as objects are given to us unless
you
really define given to us in such an
incredibly broad way that it includes
all the different things we learned by
doing science which is you know given to
us because we've worked really really
hard to get it in some sense
uh but anyway this is just my incredibly
uh under-informed take on that really
tiny excerpt from kant's enormous corpus
of writings
paul cousin says i'm curious about what
many worlds implies for the big bang is
there something special about its
version of the beginning of the universe
were there a lot of branches created
then and to which extent would they
could they differ
well i think that we don't know what
happened at the big bang right so
that's it's not clear and this is a very
short answer you know i i think that
many worlds as a theory
what many worlds really matters for
is the process of quantum measurement
right
in
something more like copenhagen
interpretation quantum measurement is
fundamental
it's an important part of the dynamics
the way function collapses
under measurement and so forth whereas
in many worlds measurement is nothing
special it's just a special case of
decoherence and branching and so forth
it's much more mechanistic and and crisp
and um
the
what happens at the big bang is not
really
very highly influenced by your opinions
about quantum measurement i think so i
don't think that there is a
straightforward good answer to what many
worlds implies for the big bang if
there's some quantum state of the
universe near the big bang that would be
just as true in many worlds or
copenhagen or whatever
the
converse might be interesting what does
the big bang imply for many worlds
uh many worlds is a story of time
evolution that is irreversible right
many worlds involves a very strong arrow
of time the fundamental ontology does
not involve that it's just a quantum
state moving in hilbert's space but the
way that it shows up in our actual world
is very highly reliant on the arrow of
time branching happens toward the future
not toward the past
and so what you need to set up the whole
theory and make it work is a quantum
state near the big bang where there
weren't that many branches right uh it
was a small number of branches in the
way that we would normally think of them
and branching happens toward the future
again i think that that's not saying
anything about the quantum state of the
universe that wouldn't be said in other
formulations of quantum mechanics but it
is a specific you know very very
important thing to say in many worlds
that we need to understand now you know
that the arrow of time depends on the
low entropy of the big bang and so
there's clearly even even in if you
didn't know about quantum mechanics
right even here as being classical even
if you're a little big boltzmann
you would be able to say yes the entropy
of the early universe was very very low
and also
many worlds require some particular
features of the wave function of the
universe at early times clearly those
are related in fact they're probably
exactly the same thing the the reality
is that there is one particular state of
the universe at the big bang and it was
a small number of branches and low
entropy which are related statements but
not exactly the same statement and then
once you get that whether you get it
from stephen hawking or some other way
of understanding the wave function
you're off to the races then you just
let quantum mechanics do its work
terrible turnip says would you be able
to describe the way in which spatial
locality arises from just a wave
function or is it too technical
well
i mean it would that would presume that
we know the way in which spatial
locality arises from just the wave
function
but
i i don't think it's too technical i
mean we have ideas i i certainly have
ideas about how that happens uh so i did
when i thought about when i read this
question i mean there is a technical way
of saying it but i think that you're
implying that you don't want the
technical way of saying it so let me say
it in a in a different way almost by way
of analogy
think of you know again particles in
newtonian physics interacting let's say
through gravity okay so or even yeah
even forget forget gravity let's say
they interact as billiard balls okay so
they're hard spheres they bump into each
other but they're in outer space a box
of billiard balls so a big box with
bouncy walls with lots of billiard balls
bumping into each other and also there's
no air in the um
in the box so there's not a lot of air
resistance or anything like that and you
could observe all these particles in the
box right and of course if they hit each
other they will bounce off and scatter
at some angle and if they don't then
they just keep going in straight
directions that's why it's better to
ignore gravity for this let's just have
them bounce into each other so hard
sphere contact interactions okay
so if you have n such particles and
we're in three dimensional space then
newtonian mechanics says you can
describe these
you can do a weekly emergent uh mapping
because you don't need to know where all
of the atoms in the billiard balls are
you just need to know the locations of
the billiard balls themselves right to
predict what is going to happen so you
have n
points in three-dimensional space and
you actually also need the momentum or
the velocity of the particles so you
have another endpoints in
three-dimensional space but
three-dimensional velocity space instead
so in total you have six n
dimensions to completely describe the
state of such a system bill your balls
bouncing around okay
and what you can do is abstract yourself
be like a mathematician and say well
that's equivalent mathematically to one
point in a 6n dimensional space and that
6n dimensional space of course is just
the phase space
the space of initial conditions for that
system of billiard balls bouncing around
in the box okay
and the nice thing is you can write down
newton's laws of physics
for the evolution of that single point
in six n-dimensional phase space right
and you don't need to know if if someone
says that you know because 6n equals
i don't know 60
so you and i know that that means
there's 10 particles but it's a 60
dimensional space right
and so you have a
a point in a 60 dimensional space and
you have some equations that tell you
how the point evolves with time
and you don't need to know
that it's ten particles in
three-dimensional space you just need to
know that it's one point in a
60-dimensional space in order to in
principle tell you how the system
evolves
okay
so you could ask yourself well how do i
know
that it really is just a highly abstract
mathematical level how do i know it
really is
points in
three dimensional space with velocities
right like where did the
three-dimensional space come from if i
could think of it
as one point in 60-dimensional phase
space
and the answer is if you look at the
laws of physics and for that one point
in 60-dimensional phase space they look
weird
they look like you know the the point in
60 dimensional phase space just sort of
moves on a straight line for a while and
then
at some weird time it sort of moves into
a different direction right
and you and i know that it moves into a
different direction because two of the
balls hit each other or one of the balls
hit the wall right
so the point is that there are two
completely equivalent ways of describing
it
one way is this abstract single point in
60 dimensional phase space another is
10
balls moving in three-dimensional space
with velocities but the latter
description even though those two
descriptions are mathematically
completely equivalent that latter
description gives you way more intuition
as we were just talking about about what
happened so more understanding you can
say oh yes the two balls scattered i saw
it happen right in front of me right
there okay that makes sense so even if
so you can imagine
some really weird counterfactual physics
where
you would just been handed that 60
dimensional
system
and
you could do experiments right you could
put a point down and watch it evolve and
see what happens
and say like what are you looking at
what is this 60 dimensional system and
eventually you would work out that oh
you know what it's actually better to
think of it as a bunch of balls moving
around in three-dimensional space with
also three-dimensional velocities
and so
that is a kind of emergence of locality
the idea of locality is there in the
ball's moving in three-dimensional space
description but it's not there
it's implicit but it's not written down
in the 60-dimensional phase space
description okay so locality is a
simplification that gives you some
handle on what happens and also some
counterfactual reasoning abilities you
can you could easily know if you if you
understand the local description in
three dimensions of space and someone
says okay i like change the initial
conditions by a little bit
what will be the difference in the
evolution if the initial conditions to
you looking at the three-dimensional
space are oh i moved that billiard ball
just before it was going to hit another
one then you know instantly what's going
on whereas if you're just given this
abstract description in 60 dimensional
space you know i don't know i just have
to run the simulation i don't know what
to what to say about it okay
so that is
morally the way that spatial locality
arises from the wave function because
the wave function is like that
point in 60 dimensional phase space
right it's the complete description of
everything in the simplest possible form
but it's not giving you
some intuition
at the down and dirty level that you can
easily extend to counter factual
situations or anything like that
but you can take that wave function
written abstractly and say well let me
chop it up into pieces in interesting
ways and what are the ways i can chop it
up into subsystems interacting with each
other that give me some intuition okay
just like the billiard balls in the
original example and the answer is if
there is spatial locality then you're
going to be able to chop up your wave
function into
different subsets that interact with
their nearest neighbors
as you
interpret it after the fact and not
interact with regions far away and so
that's a technical uh exercise to go
through to make that happen but that's
basically what you're doing when you're
talking about spatial locality arising
from the wave function i mean footnote
it doesn't arise from just the wave
function it needs to also arise from the
evolution of the wave function so either
the schrodinger equation or the
hamiltonian or however you want to put
it a wave function sitting there
statically gives you no information
about spatial locality at all
mikolaj zabo says how is the simulation
hypothesis slash argument slash whatever
a thing that people take seriously
to me it's always felt like it's just
the repackaging of good old
anthropocentrism and teleology and those
urges of humanity it's sneaking god in
back again exactly as creationism had
tried a few decades earlier by
pretending to be scientific and not
mentioning god per se also it's a
bombastic claim so the press loves it
also you can explain it using a popular
hollywood movie that everybody saw also
silicon valley people love it but how
can scientists and philosophers take
this whole hype seriously and discuss it
argue about it
well
uh
i notice in reading your uh the question
clearly there is a you know it's a it's
what we call a leading question
it's not just like how can philosophers
take this seriously or scientists take
this seriously it's like and they
certainly shouldn't right
but you didn't actually give any reason
why they shouldn't you just indicated
that you don't like it
um you know there is something called
the simulation argument and it's not
just the
there's the simulation hypothesis
okay that's one thing but there's a
simulation argument which is an argument
that says here's why i take it seriously
and the argument is
that we can easily imagine building
computers that simulate other conscious
minds and we can easily imagine building
many such computers with many such
simulations so that there are many more
conscious minds in our simulations than
not in our simulations and therefore in
the set of all possible conscious
observers that might exist in the near
future
most of them are going to live in
simulations and if that's the case
probably we live in a simulation okay i
don't necessarily buy that argument but
that is an argument and if you want to
disagree with that argument you're
welcome to do so but you disagree with
it by offering counter arguments or
pointing out logical flaws in it etc you
don't disagree with it by saying yeah it
sounds like god to me that is not really
an argument for anything
finally uh you know god is a perfectly
good thing to consider right uh i think
it's very much like the simulation
argument in that a thousand years ago
if if i could completely implausibly
imagining uh transiting my current state
of awareness back to a thousand years
ago and removing all the modern
knowledge from myself
god would have made perfect sense it
would have been a leading candidate for
understanding the world in the absence
of science and and things like that it's
not like god shouldn't be considered as
a as a hypothesis at all you should
consider it you should be a good
bayesian predict what the world would
look like if god really were the right
thing if theism or the correct ontology
compare it to naturalism etc and then in
my view it doesn't come out very well
and likewise for the simulation argument
by all means you should consider it and
then you should make predictions on the
basis of it you should compare them to
the world that we observe and you should
compare the mechanistic uh reality-based
version to the simulated version in my
mind one when doing that
i find no evidence that uh there's
anything gained by imagining that we're
living in a simulation uh and in fact i
think that i could easily argue that if
we did live in a simulation the world
would look different and so as a good
bayesian i count that against the
argument but you have to do the work you
have to do the logic you have to do the
reasoning you can't just say yeah i
don't like it
peter bamber says is there any
difference that matters to you between
thinking that we live in a simulation
determined by rules chosen by the
simulations commissioner creator and
thinking that we live in a reality
determined by rules forces mathematics
they're are part of nature
clearly a related question but i didn't
want to group them together because um
they're a little bit different in in
directionality i suppose in in thrust um
i i'm not sure like peter went to the
effort of putting is there any
difference that matters to you in
emphasis but i'm not sure what exactly
you mean by that you mean like matters
to me living my life
uh in terms of like ethics or morality
or anything like that or do you mean my
vision of the world my scientific
curiosity trying to understand the world
so
certainly
i care about whether or not we live in a
simulation or whether or not it's just
physical reality because i care about
the ultimate nature of reality otherwise
i wouldn't be doing what i do for a
living right i mean this is a
goal of mine to understand correctly the
fundamental nature of reality and that
fundamental nature of reality is
certainly very different if we live in a
simulation than if we don't so that
matters to me in that sense
uh if you mean you know do i live my
life differently then no um i don't
really have
strong feelings about how to live your
life if you do live in a simulation but
it's clearly one of those things it is
this is a similarity i think between the
simulation argument and theism
which is that
the world that we find ourselves in is
really very well described by naturalism
physicalism and
taking the world we see as base reality
so i could easily imagine either
theistic universes
or simulated universes in which the
nature of those universes as simulated
or created by god was perfectly obvious
right like god just made his
his reality known or the simulators made
it very clear or even even if the
simulators didn't make it very clear
there was various features of our world
that were very simulation-like right so
we see none of those and this is why i'm
not a fan of either theism or the
simulation argument because
you have to buy into versions of those
arguments where for whatever reason the
world ends up looking perfectly physical
and naturalistic right and so
once you get to there i don't have any
uh differences in my everyday life for
how i live whether or not i live in a
simulation
gregory kusnick says
i share your fondness for robert
heinlein's the moon is a harsh mistress
and i'm curious about your opinion of
starship troopers in particular do you
think there's merit to the idea that
citizens should have to earn the right
to vote through some sort of public
service not necessarily military service
so for those of you who don't know
robert heinlein's book starship troopers
which won hugo award for best science
fiction novel of the year
imagines a society where you can vote
it's a democracy but the right to vote
is earned rather than just given to all
citizens when they reach a certain age
and it's earned by doing some government
service the particular government
service that is focused on in the novel
is military service thus the name
starship troopers but it is it's made
clear in the novel that many other kinds
of public service uh still get you the
right to vote still gets you the
franchise
the movie that was made
with the same title is very very loosely
based on the book completely different
in spirit from the book uh the movie has
its own charms but it's not the book so
don't mix up the two of them
look and i i think that uh as a book uh
starship troopers for me just isn't
nearly as as interesting and deep and uh
fascinating as the moon is a harsh
mistress is it's a fine book
um but also i don't take too seriously
these thought experiment societies that
are investigated in these books um you
know i don't think of starship troopers
as an advertisement
for the idea that we should earn the
right to vote by public service it's a
thought experiment it it inspires you to
think about that idea so i don't think
that just because heinlein proposes that
uh idea in that book means that he was
trying to say that which should be done
maybe he did think that but i don't
think the existence of that book does it
after all there's plenty of other books
he wrote where you don't have that
system
um and also i don't think it's a good
system no very roughly speaking i don't
think it's a good system i think that i
get it and i remember there was a
question either last month or a couple
months ago about given my support and
concern for modern democracy what are
the flaws and worries that i have about
democracy
and
a possible
worry that you might have is that you're
giving the control authority over the
country over your nation
to every random person right not
necessarily to people who have any
expertise much less a vested interest in
some form
and i get that worry i appreciate that
that is a worry and i think that the
virtues of democracy are enough to
overcome that worry and i think that the
same thing is true for
investment in the country as they are
for expertise in running the country
namely that to me
the real reason to have a democracy is
not because
it is the best decision-making process
we did talk with henry farrell on the
podcast about how democracy can be a
very very good decision-making process
for very various reasons but to me
that's not the real sales pitch the real
sales pitch is people who live in a
country have an interest in it they have
desires they have values there they have
things that they want to be their own
interest to be protected right
and so therefore they have a right to
vote that's the argument for me it's not
that they're smarter or better educated
or have done more work for the country
it's just that we're trying to reflect
their interests in the most fair way
possible that's the moral argument for
democracy
you would also to really be
convincing in making an argument for
democracy you would also need to
give a sort of more practical argument
for democracy saying that this system
actually works to protect those
interests in an effective way that i
think is a harder argument to make but i
do think that there
as far as i currently believe it's it's
one of those it's not a great system but
it's better than all the alternatives
kind of kind of things uh so i actually
think everyone should get the right to
vote everyone you know above a certain
age i think that it does make sense in
any society to draw a distinction
between people who are responsible and
people who are not and i by responsible
i don't mean like you know you're you
don't lie to people or whatever or you
do what you're what what you promise to
do i just mean you're an adult you're in
sound uh mind or whatever uh whatever
whatever criteria you have for saying
okay you are
a fully credentialed member of society
and i think that every such member of
society should have the right to vote
that's my own personal belief
brendan says do you have a preference on
how to be addressed doctor professor
sean
so
for podcast purposes if you're a you
know a patreon
of the podcast or any other listener for
that matter you're perfectly uh allowed
to call me sean that's fine in my
personal goings from day to day it's
almost always people calling me sean not
doctor or professor of course this is a
timely question because in a couple of
days couple minutes i'm going to be
teaching again undergraduates and when i
was an undergraduate the system was
pretty much that you referred to your
professors as either professor or doctor
i i see no difference whatsoever between
those two things
and i suspect that is what my students
will do when i got to graduate school
then it flips and in graduate school at
least in the sciences we refer to all
the professors by their first name okay
then you've you've made the transition
you've graduated from being a student to
being a colleague once you're in
graduate school
of course there were some professors
that i had as undergraduates that were
the cool professors who wanted to be
addressed by their first names and that
was great you know it was very good when
it worked i have since you know been
um
influenced by an argument
that
it's a there's a there are hidden
subtleties unanticipated consequences of
being the cool professor who asks to be
referred to by their first name
namely that there are power
differentials and hierarchies and
expectations and amounts of respect that
are differentially given to different
kinds of professors maybe depending on
your age or your looks or your race or
your gender or whatever and the point is
that some people need to work harder to
get the respect they deserve as
professors than others do and you know
aging white dudes like myself need to
work the least hard so
it's
easy for me to say oh yeah i'm going to
be the cool professor just call me by my
first name but for other people they
need to like establish you know look i
am
credentialed i am the boss of the class
i am going to be addressed by doctor
accordingly and i i agree with that
perspective and i get it and so i think
it's just better for everyone to address
their undergraduate professors as either
doctor or professor having said that if
someone calls me by my first name i'm
not going to complain it's not a big
deal
there are more important issues out
there to worry about
eric dovighe i'm i'm combining two
questions together i'm going to group
them together here eric davie says
the possibility of unperceived existence
is weird can we conceive of a universe
with no life forms in what sense could
this universe exist to whom would it
exist sun's galaxies dust they don't
know they exist or do they and then gary
upshaw says can nothing exist so i think
these are related questions but they're
different they're importantly different
questions uh let's do gary's question
first can nothing exist
no
because
i think that there's a difference
between saying
it depends on what you mean by the
question okay there's two different
parsings of that three
word question can nothing exist one
would be
can there be something that exists and
that's something that exists is usefully
labeled as nothingness okay that's what
i'm answering no to like i think that's
a little bit of a contradiction in terms
if it exists then it's not nothing okay
but then
there's a
maybe more profound version of the
question that says could there be
nothing that exists right could there be
no existing things labeled as
nothingness or anything else
there i i don't want to give a firm
answer because i don't know because i
worry that it's an ill-formed question
because you're it's not because of the
word nothingness nothing or the word
exist but the word can
[Laughter]
can
there be nothing that exists uh what do
you mean by can
okay and this is where this is where we
need to hire the professional
philosophers to chime in here
uh i think that traditionally
sneakily implicitly when you say like
can
um we build a skyscraper a kilometer
tall or
can the universe be infinite or
something like that we're thinking about
possible actual worlds right um
whether we believe you know we're asking
questions within the realm of
plausible things feasible things or just
things that obey the laws of physics or
even things that would obey laws of
physics in different worlds with
different laws of physics we're
comparing different alternative
realities
so
the reality in which nothing exists
isn't maybe a reality right because
nothing exists in it it's not there so i
attempted to say no even to that
but that sounds like i'm saying that we
had to exist the universe had to exist
something had to exist i think this is
just tomfoolery caused by a failure of
our ability to linguistically construct
the question accurately rather than some
deep insight into the nature of reality
but i don't know like i did in my in my
paper why is there something rather than
nothing i did float the idea that maybe
the idea of nothing is just incoherent
right like that we're just not dealing
with it in a sensible way and i honestly
don't know i don't have firm feelings
about that
um to eric's question which is i think
it's more straightforward one what about
a universe that existed but had no life
in it
sure that can exist no problem i mean
after all there's plenty of places in
our universe that exist that have no
life forms in them plenty of places that
exist in our in our universe that no
life form will ever
witness the center of the sun will never
be looked at up close and personal but
it still exists right it's an
extrapolation that we think is there
because we look at the outside of the
sun and we know how physics works okay
so i don't think that uh existence needs
any sort of observation or measurement
to be there uh personally that's that's
my take
jeff b says
i'm still a bit confused about
interactions and particles in quantum
field theory from your biggest ideas
videos i understand that there is a wave
function of field configurations so when
two of these fields interacts does the
wave function branch into interacted and
non-interacted
and is there a precise way to tell where
in the field this interaction will take
place as a sub question is the
interaction location what we think of as
a particle
so last question first because that's
the easiest one no the interaction
location is not what we think of as a
particle the way it works is when you
take a field and you quantize it okay so
imagine that you have in the back of
your mind some kind of visualization of
a classical field you know some wave
that is moving through space it's
actually much harder to visualize than
you think because inevitably you
visualize waves in a two-dimensional
space but we live in three-dimensional
space and you have to visualize
something going on at every point in
space okay so that's actually hard to do
but you could do it
the quantum version of that
says that uh now you're obeying the
schrodinger equation for the quantum
fields and you solve that equation for
the different energy levels right and it
turns out that there is a single energy
level called the vacuum no energy the
lowest energy state of the quantum field
theory and then there is a set of
uh
states with a little bit higher energy
and i'm hesitating because the energies
of these states can be different numbers
but also there's different momenta okay
so what i'm getting at i should just
reveal the answer the point is that
there are states of a quantum field
theory that to you and me look exactly
like one particle
and what i why i'm talking slowly and
hesitating here is because of course the
energy of a particle can be different
but the energy of a particle in its rest
frame is a fixed thing so there's a set
of states that have both a momentum and
an energy and have the property that if
you measure the energy in the rest frame
then you will get a fixed number for all
of these different states and we call
that the mass of the particle being
described by this quantum field and then
there's another set of states that have
more energy that have at least twice as
much energy as those first set of states
and we call those two particle states
etc okay
so the single quantum field describes
simultaneously the possibility of zero
particles one particle two particles all
the way up and then we have different
kinds of quantum fields so the particle
is not an interaction location it's a
state of the field okay and now the
state of the field might be all spread
out
in which case the particle doesn't look
very particle like but if you were to
measure it somehow you would always see
it at a location and that's just a
feature that you don't measure the whole
wave function you measure there's only
certain measurement outcomes you can
possibly get
so when you're asking about the wave
function field configurations when the
the question is so i can repeat it for
clarity when two of these fields
interact does the wave function branch
into interacted and not interacted
almost okay so it's a little bit
trickier than that
let's say i have two fields an electron
field and a photon field right and they
can interact the electron can scatter
off the photon or they cannot interact
they can just go their separate ways and
so there's smooth evolution according to
the schrodinger equation that takes the
wave functions for the two fields and
entangles them and there's going to be
part where
it looks like the electron and the
photon interacted and part where it
looks like it didn't just as you say but
the only reason i'm hesitating is you
say does the wave function branch but
remember branching happens when
decoherence happens and that means
entanglement between the system and the
environment and the whole rest of the
world so
a single electron and a single photon
interacting with each other and
entangling doesn't count as branching of
the wave function if we then measured
the position or the location or the
velocity or whatever of the photon or
the electron then the coherence would
happen because measuring in that sense
means i've detected it in a macroscopic
detector that has a lot of moving parts
that's the environment and therefore
decoherence and branching did in fact
happen so once we measure it the
branching actually happens but of course
as we've said before measurement is just
a fancy way in many worlds of saying
decoherence
casey mahone says while i agree with you
that some things in the world may just
be brute facts is it really useful to
think that way it strikes me as simple
some similar to invoking the anthropic
principle rather than trying to
determine why things are one way rather
than another we have an easy fallback
option
well i would i would put it very
differently
if we admit that some things may be
brute facts it's not that we just say
and therefore they are
that's that's not being a good bayesian
right that's one of the propositions in
front of us so when we have something
like the initial conditions for the
universe okay the conditions that we see
near the big bang there is one
proposition that says
why is it like that it just is it's a
brute fact that's just a feature of the
world there is no more further
explanation to be given
there are other propositions that say
yes i can explain that in terms of the
wave function of the universe or
inflation or whatever different things
you have and you have a long list of
different claims different theories
that have different ways of explaining
or not explaining the initial conditions
of the universe and the good bayesian
says they're all
considerable they're all there they
should all have some non-zero credence
and as we investigate
it may be that we think for various
reasons that probably there is an
explanation even though we don't know
what it is or there might be reasons why
we start thinking no it's probably just
a brute fact okay so it's not giving up
it's just correctly recognizing that
sometimes that is the most plausible
looking thing for the initial conditions
of the universe i don't think that
that attributing them to brute facts is
the most plausible thing i think there's
probably better explanations but for the
existence of the universe i do think
that it's most plausible to just
attribute it to a brute fact i could be
wrong about that i don't give a hundred
percent credence i there's certainly
other possibilities even if i can't
articulate what they are so it's i don't
think it's any different than any other
option that's on the table
keith says i'm here to report that if
all 7.9 billion people on earth request
their once in a lifetime priority
question
even with easy yes no questions
answerable at the rate of one question
per second it would take you just over
250 years given that these conceivable
future patrons will be acting while
honoring the unofficial ama contract
priority question section should there
be a caveat amended to the original
contract so
when i first read this question i was
like you know what i'd be willing to try
i'd be willing to have 7.9 billion
patreon supporters that sounds pretty
awesome you're making a lot of money of
course yes there will be problems
answering all the priority questions if
you do look carefully at what i say
about the priority questions it doesn't
actually say we'll succeed in answering
them it says i will try right so i could
fail to actually succeed but it is as
keith points out a little unrealistic to
imagine spending 250 years so i decided
to wonder you know what could be the
most realistic thing that could happen
right like how how much money could i
make at this uh operation here and if i
had a hundred thousand
patreon supporters
a little bit more realistic than 7.9
billion but still not very realistic um
and they all ask questions and i gave
one second per question it'd take me a
little over a day of talking to answer
them
so that's quasi-realistic because i
wouldn't do it in a row it wouldn't just
be a day out of my life it would be a
day scattered over a week or whatever
um and so what kind of dreams of filthy
lucr would this actually correspond to
would i be the richest person on earth
and at 100 000
people giving a dollar per podcast
episode that's a hundred thousand
dollars per week except it's more like
fifty thousand dollars because there's
taxes and there's patreon taking out a
cut and all these kinds of dissipation
that we have in our financial system
uh and at that rate even if i did it you
know every week with that many 100 000
patreon supporters i figured that it
would take me pardon me if my math isn't
working out here but it would take me
about 400 years to become a
billionaire so this is not the way to
become a billionaire to have a podcast
here and support it by patreon just so
you know but it also you know it just
pinpoints how much money a billion
dollars really is and how we don't make
it by the sweat of our hands and our
brow all by itself there needs to be a
system in place to funnel money as we've
said before and there are systems in in
place that funnel lots of money to
single people but uh patreon support is
not the way to do it so not that i again
would be against having a hundred
thousand supporters that'd be great but
uh i i would try to give them more than
one second answers also so there's a
trade-off there in addition
okay chris d rubio says what is your
credence that octonions which i
understand are an eight-dimensional
analog to complex numbers will give us
deep insights into the fundamental laws
of particle physics
and there were a couple of other
octonian questions this month so i'm
just grouping them all together in in
that particular question so the very
short answer is i have no idea i'm not
an octonian expert you know i know the
basic idea of
uh maybe i don't even know the basic
idea division algebras associative
division algebras i forget exactly what
the technical math term is for these
generalizations of the complex numbers
you have the real numbers you have the
complex numbers you have the quaternions
invented by william rowan hamilton and
then you have the octonions so
one-dimensional two-dimensional
four-dimensional and eight-dimensional
and that's it in this particular
classification of things and of course
complex numbers and real numbers for
that matter have been all over physics
very very very important for physics
quaternions haven't had a lot of success
in physics you know there's a
relationship there but
most working physicists wouldn't know a
quaternion if it put them in the nose
and octonians have had almost no
success in physics there's been some
relationship to exceptional lead groups
and things like that but it's definitely
not a major thing so i can give you my
rough guess as to the answer which is
so the the real answer is i don't know
the slightly more firm answer is um
probably not i don't think it'll give us
any deep insights into the fundamental
laws of particle physics now it could be
wrong that's a proposition on which we
have credences and i will update my
credence appropriately but i think that
that kind of hope is a little bit
backwards compared to the actual
historical progress of physics you know
there's a long tradition in physics of
people falling in love with mathematical
constructions and operations and trying
to shoehorn them into physics
and as far as i know it literally never
works like it's never led to anything
really important
the important things that we have are
almost always the other way around
you start with physics and you're forced
into using some higher level math to
describe it you know einstein didn't
want to use differential geometry in his
theory of gravity he was forced to it by
thinking about the principle of
equivalence and the what he knew about
special relativity heisenberg didn't
want to use matrices he basically
invented something that was the
equivalent of matrices and
it was later pointed out to him by max
born that he just reinvented matrices
when he invented matrix mechanics later
on in gauge theories of quantum field
theory uh we realized oh look there's
topological configurations of these gage
fields we're gonna have to learn a
little bit about homotopy theory and so
forth that's almost always the way that
real progress is made so
there are plenty of mathematical
constructions that are very very
beautiful in their own right and maybe
they very well will find
use in fundamental physics someday but
it almost never happens that just
because the thing is pretty or um
compelling in some ways in some mystical
ways that mathematical constructions can
be that it will somehow probably find
usefulness in the fundamental laws of
physics
if if you have a more specific reason
why this particular thing would find use
then that's great but as i said even
quaternions which are simpler than
octonians haven't found that much use
there are quaternion
enthusiasts out there who like to
compare them or you know say it's the
right way to think about spin in quantum
mechanics etc but there are better ways
there are more useful ways to think
about spinning quantum mechanics just
using poly matrices and so forth that
don't
directly rely on calling them
quaternions or using those relations
that william roman roman hamilton
scribbled on a bridge in ireland uh many
years ago
david mcburney says i recently listened
to a podcast with marcia ricci i don't
know how to pronounce marsha's name on
the james webb space telescope she
mentioned that the two leading
candidates for the next generation of
space telescope determined by astro 2020
were focused on studying exoplanets is
that because we don't think we can do
better than jwst for looking back closer
to the big bang or because exoplanets
and the potential for finding evidence
of life is where astronomy is heading
well it's a little bit of both but let
me talk about this idea of looking back
closer to the big bang so i think i said
this before in previous podcasts but i i
want to keep saying it because i worry
that people get the wrong idea about the
james webb space telescope it's not
looking very close to the big bang okay
we have evidence of what happened 380
000 years after the big bang from the
cosmic microwave background we have very
very detailed evidence we have somewhat
cruder but still very informative
evidence from primordial nucleosynthesis
about what was going on a few seconds or
a few minutes after the big bang in
contrast jwst is looking at things maybe
that were happening a billion years
after the big bang okay maybe we can go
to hundreds of millions of years if
we're really really lucky but anyway
nowhere close to the big bang right it's
long after the actual big bang it's
early in the days of galaxy formation
and i think that was the original
selling point for jwst that it would
help us understand galaxy formation at
early times in the history of the
universe and that's great but nothing to
do with the big bang i know that david
your question didn't imply that it was
telling us about the big bang just it
was closer to the big bang but it's
still never going to get that close
there's they were these are called the
dark ages the years in between
the cosmic microwave background
formation every combination and the
lighting up of the first stars
uh it's very very hard to get any
information about what was going on
there because not that much was going on
and what was going on wasn't given off
light right that's always a little bit
of a of a hindrance when it comes to
building a telescope to look at it
on the exoplanet's idea exoplanets are a
very very high priority target for
modern astronomy right it's i wouldn't
say it's where astronomy is heading
because astronomy is not heading in any
one direction there's lots of different
directions that astronomy and
astronomers are interested in but
exoplanets are absolutely one of the big
ones and it's a perfect combination of
both super-duper interesting
and potentially accessible you know
whenever you do science it's not enough
to say this puzzle is interesting you
have to say and i can make progress on
it and by building better telescopes we
can make huge progress on understanding
exoplanets which is a really interesting
thing so i think it's a pretty natural
choice for a big next space telescope
anonymous says suppose alice commits a
crime before alice can be held
accountable for the crime she dies
alice lived in a world of highly
advanced technology so a scientist is
able to create a clone of alice so
accurate that the clone has all of her
memories
is it ethical to hold this new being
accountable for the crimes of someone
she's never met solely on the basis of
having memories that the scientist
purposefully forced her to have
i love this question this is an awesome
question good good for you anonymous um
because it highlights something i mean
this this could very easily be the basis
for a philosophy paper right uh about
the nature of personal identity and
responsibility and blame and and things
like that
and here's the way i think about it the
short answer is yes i do think that this
that she can be held uh responsible or
accountable as you put it
i i'm assuming that when you say she has
the memories i'm going to go further
than that and assuming that really
this new version of alice is essentially
indistinguishable in every way from the
old version of alice even though there
was a gap in alice's lifespan
so to me there there is no such thing
metaphysically
as the youness of your identity that
persists through time and follows you
from one moment to another
you what we think of as you are is you
are you are
a uh pattern in the collection of atoms
and molecules and stuff right and in
fact most of the particular atoms and
molecules that are in you now weren't in
you when you're a baby or whatever
that's the pattern that persists over
time
and this is a the reason why i like the
question is because it's a great example
of how we get intuitions
from the actual world in which we live
and then we use those intuitions to
build them up into purported rules of
behavior whether or not they're just
physical rules behavioral rules or even
moral ethical uh suggestions
and then we extend those rules to
situations that we haven't experienced
this happens all the time it's it's not
a bad thing it's not a mistake this is
what we do
but then we can realize either through
experience or through thought
experiments that
our extension of our experience doesn't
work
into these new situations because we
were assuming something
would always be true that really isn't
so our
knowledge our experience with moral
accountability comes from actual people
who do not die and then get
reconstructed right that's not a thing
that we have to worry about so far but
we can imagine what it would be and so i
know that this is a good intuition pump
for thinking well that new version of
alice
isn't responsible for anything she was
put together by a scientist right she
didn't do anything
but i don't think that's the right way
of thinking about it because i think
that
the notion of personal identity has to
be extended when you can imagine these
crazy thought experiments where people
don't just persist in obviously
identifiable ways from birth to death
right whether it's a star trek
transporter machine or whatever
i think what matters is that pattern is
that process
and what you're saying here is that
there's a temporal interruption in the
pattern
but it's the same pattern right the the
new alice is the same one as the old one
just with an interruption in their
lifespan
so to me
that's just as much alice as it ever was
there's no rule that says there has to
be temporal continuity there and
therefore whatever ideas about
accountability you would have had
for the original alice after she
committed a crime you should also have
for her identical version that is later
on and it does conflict with our
intuitions a little bit and therefore
our intuitions need a little bit of
upgrading i would think this is not you
know this is separate from the question
of what the
accountability should consist of
um but whatever it is i think it should
be the same for the new alice and the
old one
aleister melville says what does it mean
for a dimension to be small or curled up
aren't dimensions effectively endless in
two directions is this a concept that
falls out of the mass or doesn't yet
have any real world evidence
um
well there's no real world evidence
that's right so uh in the world in which
we live dimensions as far as we know go
on as far as we can tell dimensions of
space the three dimensions of space up
down left right forward backward but
it's very very easy to imagine
dimensions that don't right just draw a
circle a circle is a one-dimensional
mathematical structure and it does not
go on in all
forever right it's a finite size so you
can ask the question hypothetically can
we imagine dimensions of space that are
like that that are curled up and don't
go on forever or is is it even possible
that our dimensions that we do see are
curled up it's just that the they're
still never less big they're finite in
size but just very very big bigger than
our observable universe yeah these
things are just all completely um
plausible they could happen so no
there's no evidence for them but it's
not at all difficult to imagine them
happening
jake cornigay says a black hole made of
elements from a dead star would look
different inside the event horizon than
a black hole made of cats and people who
happen to fall inside of a black hole
while studying it at least briefly right
so when we speak of black holes only
having the characteristics of mass spin
and electric charge isn't that shorthand
for what they look like outside the
event horizon while very different
interiors must exist across space time
uh short answer is yes absolutely but
we often speak of black holes as what
they look like from the outside because
once you go inside you're dead or at
least you can't talk to the people
outside about what you're seeing so yes
when we say that black holes are
characterized by mass spin and electric
charge we do mean
by as far as what they look like outside
is concerned
daniel c says i would appreciate if you
could speak in a bit more detail as to
this argument against strong emergence
in the form you refer to it you mention
a recent ama that strong emergence would
violate locality which sounded like a
reason to reduce your prior for it is
this a violent is this violation of
locality your biggest qualm with strong
emergence does the fact that locality is
not fundamental and seems to break down
when gravity is strong enough open the
possibility that there is in fact other
non-local behavior in lower gravity
conditions but it is just not as easily
visible to us particularly when we try
to resolve the universe of the scale of
individual particles
so yeah there's a lot going on here in
this question and this is you know by
the way for those of you who are
contemplating future ama questions this
is about as long as the question should
ever be you know despite my
protestations people are just quite
loquacious in their ama questions
sometimes and some of the questions
would be good if you just wrote them
shorter but you just can't resist can
you so anyway daniel's question is about
the limit where i'm willing to read it
out loud and then and try to tackle it
here um
so the idea is that
the
there's this idea of the laws of physics
underlying our everyday lives okay the
core theory
and it is very very very very very very
well
delineated as an ordinary quantum field
theory
which implies the word local to it and
what that means is that all the laws of
the dynamical laws that tell us how the
quantum fields evolve with time over the
course of evolution
can be derived from an expression
whether it's it could be the hamiltonian
or lagrangian or whatever there's
different ways of writing down the
expression but the expression takes the
form something specific happening
individually at individual locations in
space okay so quantum fields only
interact with each other at the same
locations in space the value of a
quantum field at one location does not
directly affect the value of the quantum
field or the evolution of a quantum
field at any other location in space
if you poke it or if something happens
to the fields there can be
ripples that spread out but those
spreading outs only happen at the speed
of light or more slowly than that so
that's locality now that locality might
be
broken by gravitational effects but
those gravitational effects are
completely 100 invisible in our everyday
lives you know they're important for
quantum gravity and for black holes they
do not affect us and so i think that the
people who care about strong emergence
would not be able to lean on that
particular potential violation of
locality i don't think locality is
fundamental i think locality is an
emergent approximation but my point is
that in the world in which we live in
our everyday lives the lives of human
beings that approximation is super duper
good so you don't want to really rely at
a deep level on violating that somehow
now the relation to strong emergence
is basically the idea that there's
no
if you believe that that is true if you
believe that we have written down the
laws of physics underlying everyday life
and it takes the the um form of locality
or of a local quantum field theory
there's two ways to say what is
basically the same thing
one is that the fact that the laws of
physics are local means that what is
happening at one point in space like
what does the electron do located at one
point in space
it responds to what the other quantum
fields are doing at the same point in
space
period full stop okay so therefore all
of the hopes of the strong emergentists
that it basically come down to the idea
that an electron would behave
differently
if it were in a rock or in a brain or an
interstellar space even
if its local conditions of the other
fields at the same point in space were
the same okay
and so that's just incompatible with
locality
full stop you're done
now maybe locality is wrong so okay good
good for you
but that's an enormous
kind of thing to
break about fundamental physics i
predict that if you try to break it you
will fail or you'll come up with some
theory that is wrong for other reasons
the idea that you can just wave your
hands and say ah maybe it's broken
is entirely unconvincing you gotta show
me exactly how it's broken because these
things all depend on each other but the
other way to say basically the same
thing is the core theory works okay it's
pretty good and you gotta violate it and
you have to violate it
by violating locality in this particular
case but more importantly you have to
violate it so if you're gonna violate it
tell me how that's my only claim that's
my only request of the strong
immersionists don't just say well it'll
be violated you have to tell me exactly
how we have equations for the chord
theory that are enormously well tested
and if you're going to violate them tell
me what equations you're going to use
instead tell me how to how to modify the
equations that we have that is not too
much to ask when you're messing with our
best understanding of the fundamental
laws of physics
ariel assaf says to what extent do you
think we are capable of understanding
the universe we clearly are able to make
extraordinary predictions but on the
other hand even if we are touring
complete we implicitly accept occam's
razor we rely on counterfactuals and our
reasoning etc what confidence should we
have that we can grasp the laws of
nature well you know i think it's a back
and forth right i think that we
guess and hope that we can understand
the laws of nature and then we
on the basis of those guesses try to do
it
and we either succeed or fail and so far
we've been doing extraordinarily well
right i mean like i just talked about
with the core theory our understanding
of the laws of nature in the regimes
where we really tested things
is honestly way better than has any
right to be this is a good news bad news
situation good news for us in terms of
the accomplishments that human beings
have made throughout history bad news
for physicists because it's hard to
improve your theory when it works so
well now
that's not proof
that we will definitely be able to
understand all the laws of nature but i
see absolutely zero obstacle to doing
that so
other than some vague thing that you
know anything could happen so who knows
which is always true but not very
persuasive
um i'm not moved by arguments that maybe
we cannot ultimately grasp the laws of
nature
charles hot says in an early ama you
said something along the lines of if you
believe in science and want to push
naturalism forward then you should also
listen to the science of convincing
people
with this in mind how do you feel about
the effects of the so-called militant
atheist naturalists such as christopher
hitchens ricky gervais and richard
dawkins do you think that by being more
debate driven rather than empathetic
they are doing more harm than good in
this area
well you know i can't speak for them
about what their goals were right like
sometimes you want to persuade people
who are on the fence but other times you
just want to say things that you think
are true you just want to get something
off your chest right and maybe tell some
jokes or whatever it is so i don't think
you can criticize them as
not
following the best science about how to
persuade people unless they've said my
goal is to persuade people and this is
what i'm trying to do then you could
persuade them but i don't know of them
actually saying that
furthermore i do think that there have
been
both good and bad repercussions of the
whole sort of new atheist discussion
that we had in the early 2000s the good
part is atheism
is much more on the table these days
than it ever was as a point of view that
needs to be taken seriously and
respected you know when in the 80s
people just wouldn't take atheism
seriously at all and now it is at least
recognized even if you don't accept it
you have to confront it you have to deal
with it right it's just much more a
place of the table kind of thing
at the same time there have undoubtedly
been people who've been turned off by
the
debate
their uh derogatory kind of attitude of
the
conversations that were had back then
i have no way of knowing of quantum
quantifying what the relative sizes of
these effects are what i know is that
people who are sympathetic to one side
or the other might cherry pick and say
like oh this thing i like or this thing
i don't like and i don't see it any way
to actually measure it but
you know it depends on what your goals
are so
i really don't know what the overall
effect is but i think that my guess is
it's been good
i don't have any evidence for that but
there you go
ikey iki e-i-k-e piersdorf says
some scientific theories capture the
public imagination in ways that others
don't recently constructor theory has
been hailed as a new approach to doing
science yet the only people i hear
talking about it are the inventors
thereof there's no sitcom no flurry of
popular science books about constructor
theory what do you think is the
difference between a scientific theory
that is a mainstay of public excitement
and one that is more or less ignored
even if within its own domain it might
be just as important
well i think there's two things going on
here one is the relative importance or
attention being paid to new scientific
theories within the realm of
professional science
and the other is the relationship
between that and how much attention is
given to scientific theories outside the
realm of professional science
so constructor theory is not paid that
much attention within professional
science maybe because it's brand new
maybe because there's not been any
tangible results coming out of it uh
maybe because people just don't like it
when they do hear about it but for
whatever reason um there it's a minority
pursuit like i i kind of think that
there's something interesting there but
i'm not dropping everything to do it
myself just like i would say with
stephen wolfram's stuff right like i'm
glad other people are doing it but i'm
not going to do it i don't personally
think it's the most promising way
forward but i'm happy if it turns out to
be right they should i'm glad that some
people are doing it i would say if
anything the amount of attention being
paid to constructor theory in the public
domain is quite a bit larger than the
amount that is paid to it by
professional scientists i mean you can
walk through the physics departments of
major universities throughout the world
you're not going to find a lot of people
working on constructor theory but you
will find it discussed in popular
magazines and on podcasts and things
like that okay
so that's a more general question you
know should the amount of attention
given to scientific ideas in the popular
domain be equal precisely to the same
amount of attention that is given in the
in the scientific domain
well no i don't think it needs to be i
do think that we should
be honest with the public i think that
we should try to be very clear when we
talk about a scientific idea do not only
say what we think the arguments for and
against it are but recognizing that none
of us is perfect and that other people
are also smart and have their own
reasons for believing things we should
share how respectable or popular or
influential it is within the realm of
professional scientists
so you know when i talk about many
worlds i'm always very quick to say
there's plenty of other people who don't
believe it there's other options out
there on the table i'm going to give you
the arguments that i believe make many
worlds very attractive and those are the
arguments i think are right but i'll say
but you know there are other people who
disagree
so
i see no problem with people who are
enthusiasts about constructor theory or
whatever both writing their scientific
papers and talking about it to the wider
world
um but they should just be honest that
it's a it's a minority pursuit that's
fine right and and i think that's more
or less the way it works you know like
people complain that string theory gets
so much more
hype than loop quantum gravity does but
again
the relative importance of string theory
to loop quantum gravity is much greater
among professional physicists than it is
among the public loop quantum gravity
gets way more play in the public than it
does among professional physicists it
doesn't get zero among professional
physicists but is a very tiny minority
pursuit compared to something like
string theory
qubit says can you tell us your thoughts
on quantum darwinism proposed by voice
zurek my impression is that this concept
tries to solve the measurement problem
only using the schrodinger equation i
don't see any difference to the many
worlds theory however i have the
impression that zurich doesn't like to
talk about other worlds what are your
thoughts
you know i don't like to uh
imagine that myself in the mindset of
somebody else so i can't tell you what
zerek is thinking or doesn't like to
talk about he did just this week come
out with a new comprehensive review
article on quantum darwinism etc so you
can check that out you just google it or
go to the archive and look for xerx
papers
for those of you who don't know what
we're talking about vojtech zurek at los
alamos is one of the leaders in
understanding decoherence and has been
for a very long time han stiederze who
was really one of the biggest pioneers
passed away recently
and i think that this understanding of
decoherence is crucially important to
understanding quantum mechanics in the
real world so i'm a huge booster of this
work
zurek in particular has done more than
anybody to help understand why when we
do branch the wave function or if you
like when we do observe a quantum system
we see certain states and not others
pointer states as they are called okay i
think this is again crucially important
insights into how reality works i'd be
very very happy if zurek shares a nobel
prize at some point for improving our
understanding of how the classical world
emerges from quantum mechanics quantum
darwinism in particular uh is something
that's sort of a more specific
set of ideas within that program that i
haven't personally found very useful yet
but that's just not a uh
disagreement with the idea it's just
that you know some ideas are useful to
your own research and some are not okay
um i do i do think that my favorite way
of thinking about xerx work and the
equations is is squarely within the idea
of the many worlds formulation and now
people slice and dice what they define
to be many worlds to me as long as the
fundamental ontology of your theory is a
vector in hilbert space and the
fundamental dynamical equation is the
schrodinger equation you're doing many
worlds okay that's the important thing
to define what you mean by the theory
but different people have their
different sub versions of it and that's
fine that's a healthy research program
with people trying out different ideas
and so zurich has his own set of ideas
within what i would call many worlds but
he would call it you know his own kind
of interpretation right and so that's
fine and the proof of the pudding is in
the tasting we'll see which set of ideas
and concepts is actually most useful
moving forward but i do think that his
work is front and center in addressing
some of the most important questions
that there are to be asked out there
keith
says if sending particles through a
stern gerlock device measures their spin
how does one go about aligning the spin
of two particles without measuring them
or is this just a non-practical idea
that only gets proposed in thought
experiments
i'm not sure what you mean by aligning
the spin of two particles um if you mean
like creating a
uh entangled epr pair like one particles
up and the others down or vice versa
that's very easy to do just let a
particle with no spin decay into two
particles with spin and then the fact
that momentum is conserved will tell you
that the two spinning particles have
anti-aligned spins there you go very
easy to do
but it's also easy to take two electrons
that are not created by the decay of a
particle and align their spins you know
you just measure the spins of both of
them there you go
if you measure the spin to both of them
and they're both spin up then they're
aligned right i mean maybe what you want
to do is put them into an entangled
state but that's also possible to do you
just let them interact in a certain way
or you take one particle and you just
modulate it like if you have two
particles that are both spin up you can
do things to just one of the particles
that flips its spin upside down and then
they're anti-lined if you want it to be
that way so this is very practical idea
i'm not the guy to ask about what is the
most practical way to do it in some
particular technological instantiation
of this but it is very very doable
jeffrey seagal says
regarding the simon conway mars podcast
i was confused in that he starts off by
saying that the combinatorial immensity
of biological space is stupidly large
but then he seems to imply that
evolution could find optimal solutions
arguing that mammals were always going
to win out over the dinosaurs and that
convergent evolution was to be expected
it seems to me that in limited time
scales over which species evolve it
would be highly unlikely that the
optimal solution in biological space
would be found
so
i'm very very happy to talk about stuff
that happened in recent and past
podcasts but we have to keep in mind i
am not the expert here on biology right
i mean this is a question for conway
mars not for me
having said that i mean you're certainly
correct that because the combinatorial
immensity of biological space is
stupidly large we're never going to find
the truly optimal solution in any exact
sense but on the other hand who cares
about that it's not even clear that
there is a sensible idea of the truly
optimal solution in biology because the
conditions that we live in are always
changing right i mean it's a it's a race
against the changing environment and the
changing competition from other species
that real biological organisms live in
so it's not really a matter of the
super-duper exact optimal solution it's
a matter of
a pretty good solution a good enough
solution which is a better sort of
characterization than optimal and i
think that was the point and again i'm
not going to defend whether the point is
true or not but the point was that
there is
on the one hand a lot of things that
biology can do but on the other hand a
sufficiently small number of constraints
it's trying to satisfy
that it has enough freedom to find a
more or less pretty good solution that
could be found by a very different
trajectories right that's the
convergence of evolution that even
though the path that you take through
the space of genomes and through the
space of environments might be very
different at the end of the day you end
up with more or less the same morphology
the same shape and size and habits as a
grown-up organism that you would have in
either one of those two trajectories so
they're not going to be exactly the same
it won't be a perfectly optimal solution
but will be good enough
i mean more generally i would say that i
think a lot of questions in both
philosophy and science
suffer a lot of opinions or ideas
suffer from
over emphasizing perfection and
exactness right the world is not perfect
or exact and when you relax the demand
for perfection or exactness a little bit
your impression about what is possible
and what actually happens might change
by a lot uh that's an easy thing to say
very hand wavy thing but i do think
that's a general impression that i have
alexandra bates says what do you think
of the effective altruism movement have
they changed your personal actions or
views on anything do you think their
method of improving the world is
effective
well you know i think that there's sort
of the strong or weak versions of
being an effective altruist and
maybe the weak version is so weak that
it's just common sense but i think it's
true namely that if you're going to be
altruistic at all
if you're going to give money to
charities etc
because you think you're doing some good
for the world and maybe that's what
you're telling yourself are you doing
some good for the world
then i think it's pretty much true that
it would be better to do more good for
the world
i don't think it's a radical kind of
idea so in other words
being a little bit more conscious of
what your altruism is actually doing
and deploying it in ways that are most
effective seems to be a very sensible
thing to do and maybe something that
isn't always done right if you look at
what money
actually goes to
i don't think anyone could argue that
we're trying to optimize for the
effectiveness of it
um now it can go too far right and i so
there's a stronger version that says yes
we should
run our own personal lives as if our
goal was to optimize the
utility or happiness of the world i
don't think that's realistic i don't
think it's what anyone actually does i
don't think that's what uh is ever going
to happen so i don't think i think
that's too strong but maybe you know
it's some optimal point that we can keep
in mind as we do our actual moves
through the world so you know i do think
that it's a kind of an idea that
just the phrase and the the general idea
can work to push people in slightly
better directions but in the real world
of course people don't
people don't become altruist people
don't give money let's just call it
giving money to keep things definite
people don't give money simply because
they want to optimize the utility of the
world that's not the only reason why
they give money there might be some
personal cause that they care about they
want to give to the alma mater that they
graduated from or they want to donate
within the
sphere they care about you know here at
mindscape we have a
scholarship that we're giving and i
didn't sit down and carefully think
about what is the scholarship i could
give that would maximize the happiness
of the world
i saw a need or usefulness for a
particular kind of targeted scholarship
that i thought would be useful to give
that's why i kind of like the version
that was promulgated by joshua green
when we had him on the podcast where
there's sort of a mixed strategy
where you allow people or you encourage
people to both give money to their
favorite charity to like you know save
their local kittens at the cat shelter
and also something that has been
optimized for saving the most lives or
something like that that makes people
happy and tickles their desire to focus
on their personal uh favorite ideas i
think that's a perfectly legit
taroun says priority question remember
priority questions are the ones as we've
discussed you get to label a question
priority and i will try my best to
answer it with the caveat that you only
get one priority question in your whole
life okay and i'm counting on you to not
abuse that privilege so tarun says you
identified my strategy in the last ama
i've been going through my list of most
burning questions each month and now i'm
asking one of the questions you didn't
answer previously as a priority question
in the last ama i mentioned that a good
game theorist would say like given that
you only are able to ask a priority
question once in your life you wouldn't
just answer use it on the first question
that came to mind you would try to get
the questions answered anyway and then
when that didn't work you would label
them priority apparently that's what
tyrone has been doing so good for him
the question is much has been made of
laws of physics relating to motion
whether deterministic or random ruling
out libertarian free will doesn't
einstein's block universe give us an
equally good reason do not believe in
libertarian free will given that the
future is fixed i'd be very interested
to get your thoughts on this perspective
well yeah but the idea is that the block
universe is
not
actually real not correct because the
laws of physics are not classical
the block universe has to be upgraded a
little bit in quantum mechanics and the
way in which it gets upgraded might
differ from formulation to formulation
in many worlds it gets upgraded to a
block wave function i guess you want to
call it but that wave function describes
multiple worlds multiple blocks multiple
universes
and you cannot make predictions at any
one moment of time even if you were
laplace's demon and knew everything
about what any individual observer would
find themselves observing later on in
the universe so it's just not
deterministic in that way
uh the wave function as a whole evolves
deterministically but that is utterly
irrelevant for human experience because
we don't live in the wave function as a
whole we live on a branch and of course
in other versions of quantum mechanics
it is truly stochastic in which case it
is not a block universe that is
determined by our present configuration
you can still think of it as a blocked
universe but not one that is fixed by
present conditions so i think that the
block universe is kind of irrelevant to
the question of free will determinism or
non-determinism or the laws of physics i
also think is irrelevant to free will as
a compatibilist but it's very relevant
to the question of libertarian free will
if the universe is deterministic within
a single universe then you can't have
libertarian free will but that's
prior to the question of whether or not
there's a black universe right if the
universe is not deterministic then that
simplistic notion of a block universe is
incorrect so it's not really helpful in
figuring out whether it's libertarian
free will
nalita s says i was wondering what your
thoughts are in terms of the first law
of thermodynamics and understanding us
humans as quantum systems what happens
to our energy after death does it die
with us does it evaporate like a black
hole does it transform into another form
like dirt
this is an easy one actually yeah it
doesn't go anywhere it's like saying
where does the energy of a candle go
when it stops burning the burning was a
conversion of the energy that was in the
candle from one form to another by a
combustion oxidation
and the burning is a process that stops
and life in a living organism is exactly
the same thing the energy is in the
organism it's doing something it's
undergoing a process it's living and
that process stops but the energy
doesn't go anywhere it's still there you
have exactly the same amount of energy
the moment after you die as the moment
before
brian keating says do you see any place
for nfts or blockchain technology in
science and or publishing proof of stake
versus embargoes etc so brian by the way
is a an astrophysicist an observational
cosmologist uc san diego and host of his
own podcast into the impossible where
i've been known to appear so you can
check that out uh but the short answer
to this question for me is no i don't
really see any special place not in the
sense that i
see the lack of a place like i'm
predicting that there won't be any place
but i don't see any particular special
need for nft or blockchain technology
in science or publishing right now um
i think it's kind of the opposite i mean
i think that in modern science the way
that you
claim something is to make it public you
know it's it's a weird thing that back
in the day they used to get a result you
know newton or galileo or whatever and
they wouldn't want to publish it uh and
they would but they would want to claim
priority to it so they would write it in
a fake language or in a code or backward
or an anagram or something like that
i think we're beyond that now and i
think that we just put the result out
there and whoever puts the result out
there first gets priority for it i think
it's a pretty good system actually
because it incentivizes
sharing the scientific results as much
as possible which is good for science um
now of course i'm only familiar with my
own little kind of science it might not
work that well in other areas like areas
that are economically or politically
meaningful unlike mine so who knows
there might be other uses that i don't
know about but i don't see it in the
areas that i'm familiar with
kyle stevens says i'm curious to learn
more about the logistics of your
podcasts do you record many in a short
period of time or are they recorded once
per week are the length of your podcast
limited by your time availability or the
availability of the guests or have you
just found the current length to be the
best
i think it's all very variable you know
i'm just not very systematic about these
things i think i might need to be more
systematic now that i'm teaching every
week and that's a more of a weekly
constraint on my time than i had before
but sometimes i'll do a bunch of
podcasts in a row other times it's
roughly once a week or whatever it
depends mostly on the availability of
the guests and me at the same time the
usual coordination problem there
i don't want to record too many like i
did record a bunch
before i moved across the country
because i knew that would be soaking up
my time so i'm i'm still going through
some of those and i feel bad because
people are getting delayed quite a bit i
did rick biatto months ago
and i had people i haven't actually
released yet because sometimes you know
someone has a book coming out and i will
try to
organize the release of the podcast
around the book coming out like for
example i have a book coming out
on september 20th we're releasing uh the
biggest ideas in the universe volume one
did i not say that boy i'm very bad at
this
uh yeah we're releasing
volume one of the biggest ideas in the
universe in book form and so i will it
will be clear to podcast listeners
because i will try anyway i haven't done
it yet but i will try to put out a solo
podcast talking about some of the thing
of the themes in the book now the book
is not about new sexy physics um it's
about good old established physics and
so it's not like it's going to be
speculative or anything like that but
there's still things to be said
about
the ideas themselves and the best way to
talk about them and think about them so
when that happens when a book is uh
coming out and therefore the podcast
episode release date is
scheduled accordingly it might push back
people who i've done on the podcast who
have recorded but who don't have a
deadline or anything like that so some
people are still waiting for their
episodes to be released sorry about that
people who are like that but uh usually
i don't like to record too far in
advance for exactly that reason i try to
be really really considerate of the
guests they're busy people they're
giving me their time
i don't want to record something with
them and then release it six months
later that's a little bit annoying to
them and likewise i don't want to spend
hours and hours of their time which they
rarely have right so i think about
between an hour and an hour and a half
is a good
compromise between the idea of just sort
of rambling on for hours and hours and
uh going too briefly to actually say
anything substantive so i think that
roughly
works i don't know what it is about the
time scale of an hour that is so
compatible with this i mean maybe it's
just because i'm used to giving talks or
going to classes that'll last that long
i'm not really sure
seth holowenko waco says can you think
of any meaningful differences that might
exist in science and society if we
decided tomorrow that the north was
actually down rather than up and that
the earth and other planets actually
rotated clockwise around the sun etc it
seems like north has an arbitrarily
arbitrary positive value assigned to it
that makes references to north as
opposed to south the right way i can't
help but think that as a resident of the
northern hemisphere who can literally
see the north star and grew up in a
northern state i have some kind of minor
implicit bias or privilege that is
wholly unwarranted
i think in a minor way there could be
you know people have absolutely pointed
out and even made maps reflecting the
fact that we could very easily
arbitrarily choose to put what we now
call the southern hemisphere at the top
of our maps then again you know up and
down are also pretty arbitrary uh when
it comes to maps and things like that so
these are all arbitrary choices
and it is
maybe possible that our putting the
northern hemisphere at the top
privileges it in some way on the other
hand a lot more people live in the
northern hemisphere of the earth in the
southern hemisphere of the earth so it's
not a completely arbitrary
choice
i think that among the many implicit
biases and privileges that people have
that's one of the more minor ones and
you have to pick your battles we're all
finite creatures i think i'm not gonna
spend too much effort on that particular
battle
chris murray says how do you reconcile
the bekenstein bound with the fact that
even a single real number requires an
infinite amount of information to
describe our world seems to have real
numbers all over the place so what is
the right way to think about this the
beckenstein bound relates the
information or entropy
that we can squeeze into a certain
region of the universe of a fixed size i
mean basically there's only so many
things you can do in a region
uh if you try to do more than that you
make a black hole right and that has a
finite amount of entropy
but you know sometimes this is casually
described as a bound on the amount of
information that can be put into a
region but there's a subtlety here i
mean as you might expect there's lots of
subtleties here um when we have quantum
mechanics when we talk about the quantum
state of a system there's lots of
subtleties going on especially the fact
that individual systems that are
entangled with the outside world don't
have wave functions of their own and
they need to be described using density
matrices okay that's a complication but
one that isn't completely relevant here
here's a more relevant one um when you
have a quantum state even of just a
single spin right you have on the one
hand just two states that you could
measure the spin to be in you measure
the spin with respect to some axis and
if it's a spin one half object then it's
either spin up or spin down just two
states but before you measured it
there is an infinite amount of
information required to specify the
state because it is a linear combination
of spin up and spin down there's an
angle between the spin up axis and the
spin down axis and that angle could be
any real number right
in fact in a single spin is described by
a two-dimensional space of possibilities
called the block sphere and a sphere
just like a real number has an infinite
number of points okay
but
when we we don't we're not talking about
that when we talk about the information
or the number of states that there can
be inside a black hole we're referring
to the number of possible measurement
outcomes even if you're not measuring it
well we're really what i'm trying to say
is referring to the number of basis
states that are going into the state the
dimensionality of the space not the
specific state that is within that
n-dimensional space okay so it's not a
real numbers worth of information that
is required to tell you what quantum
states form the basis
for the system we're looking at to pick
out the specific quantum state does in
fact require a continuum information but
we never do that we never have that
information we don't have access to it
we all of our measurements only have a
finite resolution right so anyway but
the but the technical answer to this
question is the thing that is being
limited by the beckenstein bound is the
number of basis states not the amount of
information required to fully specify
the linear combination of such basis
states that would make you an arbitrary
quantum state or wave function
bill warner says normally the hotter the
thing is nothing is the higher the
entropy but i often hear that the early
universe was very hot and very low in
entropy can you help me understand this
yes the early universe is not normal in
that sense i mean when you say normally
you mean like things you see around you
in the everyday world if you have
a cup of liquid with a fixed volume of
liquid then the higher ent the higher
temperature state that that liquid is in
the higher entropy it is in that is true
and remember what entropy is really
telling you is the number of microstates
or microarrangements that give you that
macrostate so the reason why there's
more entropy for a higher temperature
thing is because the distribution of
individual velocities momenta of the
molecules making it up is broader right
in a higher temperature state that tells
you the average kinetic energy but
there's a distribution of actual kinetic
energies and if the average is higher
that means there's sort of more
individual ways for the specific
velocities and momentum to be
distributed and therefore higher entropy
but the world is not a liquid at fixed
volume in a cup of coffee okay so it's
just more complicated than that
in the early universe it is true that it
is high temperature and there's this
sort of
weird ill-defined discourse that
cosmologists throw around where they say
that the matter degrees of freedom are
high entropy in the early universe but
the gravitational degrees of freedom are
not
that's more or less ill-posed in every
way and that's not words you should ever
say out loud
for one thing it's not degrees of
freedom gravitationally that are low
entropy because gravitational degrees of
freedom are gravitational waves or
gravitons okay and those are not what is
being referred to what's being referred
to is the configuration of the matter
fields in the presence of strong
gravitational fields or by strong we
just mean gravitational fields that
matter as far as entropy is concerned
they don't want the the
in the presence of these gravitational
self interactions higher entropy means
lumpier generally the thing about the
liquid in the cup of coffee or whatever
is that its
self-gravitational interactions are
completely irrelevant the gravitational
force from one coffee molecule to
another one
doesn't affect its uh configuration very
much but in the early universe the
gravitational interaction between one
part of the universe and another is
crucially important it could have been a
black hole right
or it could have been at least very
lumpy with lots of black holes scattered
around or even strong
concentrations of matter surrounded by
empty spaces even if they're not
literally black holes so when you just
go through the details the lumpy
configuration of the early universe is
much higher entropy than a smooth
configuration would be regardless of
what temperature it's at
jesse rimler says effective altruists
recommend giving to charity and career
selection as the best ways for ordinary
people to do good what about effective
organizing civil rights and labor laws
came about not through donations and
people making taking career quizzes
rather ordinary people built complex
networks worked in solidarity tried
various tactics and often put their
bodies on the line to accomplish
long-lasting change do you think the ea
movement focuses less on this because
these actions are harder to quantify
well i don't know why they do that again
i'm not trying to read people's minds
i do think that you could easily just
try to make an argument rather than
phrasing it in terms of rhetorical
questions you could say
the actual best way to affect the world
is not to earn a lot of money and then
give it away but to put in the same
amount of effort into making the world a
better place by organizing or by you
know fixing things or whatever it is
these are all very very hard things to
do and so i don't think you should be or
we should be too definitive in our
statements about what would actually
make the world a better place i think we
should think about it and talk about it
and be open-minded about the
possibilities
certainly if i do if i did sort of um
uh stoop to psychoanalysis here which is
always dangerous and wrong but you know
maybe we can temporarily uh do that
i do think that when it comes to
effective altruists there's sort of a
crisp rigorous rational feeling about
distributing our charitable dollars
right that is something where it's kind
of straightforward and sensible to say
we're trying to do good for the world by
giving money away what's the best way to
do that whereas when it comes to
organizing or you know protesting or
making the world a better place
through demonstrations things get very
emotional very quickly and it might be
that the kind of people who are into
effective altruism just are turned off
by that kind of emotionality right and i
think that the correct balance to strike
is a tricky question i'm not going to
try to come down on it i think that
emotionality and passion are very very
important they're not mistakes when it
comes to making the world a better place
there's at any one point in our lives
there are literally an infinite number
of things you can do like right now
sitting listening to the podcast there
are an infinite number of actions you
could take within the next five minutes
right uh they might not be dramatically
different from each other you could walk
to the left you could walk to the right
as we were just talking about there's an
infinite number of directions you can
walk in so it's not a very meaningful
infinity
but the point is we make decisions
implicitly
all the time about what actions to
actually take
and emotions and passions are really
important drivers of getting us off up
off our butts to do more difficult
actions the world is a certain way and
it's very often easy to just let the
world go on being the way it is and you
know not worry ourselves too much about
improving it
and sometimes getting worked up about
the state of the world matters it helps
it's important and that's hard to
analyze at a perfectly rational level
sometimes so again it might be possible
that the kind of
psychological states that lend
themselves to be an effective organizer
are different than the kinds of
psychological states that lend
themselves to figuring out how best to
allocate our charitable donations okay
i'm in favor of both i don't think it's
a competition between them
frank layman says for you what was the
peak era of the internet in terms of
feeling of promise excitement usefulness
uniqueness not horribleness etc
so i'll give you two answers to this one
is that's probably not a good question
to ask i think it's it's probably very
much like asking what was the peak era
of the automobile in 1925 asking that
question you weren't at the peak era of
the automobile yet the automobile was
still pretty new i don't think we're
anywhere near an equilibrium state for
the internet right now so asking what
was what was its peak era is probably
wildly premature uh having said that i
think that the obvious answer is right
now you know i mean as terrible as the
internet is in many ways it's also
really useful and really good in many
ways one of which is
wait for it
letting podcasts out there in the world
and letting us listen to podcasts right
you know it's it's too easy
to find terrible things on the internet
that's certainly true and it's too easy
to be terrible on the internet you know
responding to things thoughtlessly
spreading your not very considered
opinions out there more widely than we
could ever before these are all things
that can get us into trouble and can be
irritating but there's also genuine
goodness out there and i do think that
the consumer
needs to take some responsibility for
going out and finding the good stuff on
the internet not being too
focused on being annoyed at the bad
stuff
josh charles said if it's possible that
space is an emerging property out of
entanglement is it possible that we'll
find spooky action at a distance is not
really distant at all since locally it
would seem like it was spatially close
uh again two answers to this
you know i think when i talk about and i
think when everyone talks about space
being emergent property out of
entanglement it does not follow
that two entangled particles are close
that is not i know that it sounds like
it does but it really doesn't um because
when i talk about when i in my
scientific technical work the ideas that
we have been exploring about distance
being relation related to entanglement
the
entangled systems that we're talking
about are empty space
not particles okay and that's because
for a very good reason there are far far
more quantum degrees of freedom in empty
space in their vacuum states than there
are particles even at the center of a
neutron star or something like that most
of space is empty as far as quantum
field theory is concerned so when you're
talking about the geometry of space it's
only the empty space degrees of freedom
that matter not the particles
now one can be more bold as maldasena
and suskind are with the er equals epr
conjecture and suggest that even two
entangled particles have in some sense a
tiny quantum wormhole connecting them it
is still after some effort unclear to me
what sense that is
the places where the er equals epr
conjecture works very well
are places where or at least is very
clear
are places where there's an enormous
amount of entanglement between what is
basically different regions of empty
space making a big macroscopic wormhole
when it comes to just a single particle
at a time it's not clear what that
wormhole is supposed to be telling us
okay so that's one sort of technical
answer to the question the other is that
the phrase is not really distant at all
might not be relevant in this context
because in in again in the way that i
think about spatial locality arising
from entanglement the entanglement is
absolutely more fundamental right the
entanglement comes first
and you just define distances in a way
that is a convenient way of talking
about the entanglement structure of the
system and predicting its future
evolution etc etc so my way of thinking
is that the spooky action at a distance
isn't that spooky because it's not
really at a distance it's just action
that's all it is it's just a wave
function evolving through space time
or wave function evolving in time i
should say in space emerging out of it
so in other words let me back up and be
more clear about this
almost everyone including most modern
physicists thinks of things happening
inside space-time even if they know
about quantum gravity not everyone but a
lot of people just think that way deep
down and certainly einstein thought that
way deep down
i think that we should be thinking about
wave functions evolving in hilbert space
not in space time at all so to me the
spooky thing is not that action happens
at a distance the weird thing the thing
that needs to be explained is that the
idea of distance and locality makes
sense at all is a useful emerging
concept right so it's it's completely
backwards it's not like here is space
here is action at a distance in space
isn't that weird the the question to be
answered is why is there space at all
and why is there a such a good
approximation to think that actions from
one quantum system to another seem to be
not at a distance in this emergent space
i think we have answers to that these
are not implacable questions or these
are not impossible questions uh but but
that's a very different way of framing
the question then oh my goodness there
are these actions at a distance what are
we going to do about that
sandy mcdonald says my handle on
mathematics stopped at high school level
recently i've been feeling that i might
get more from your and other authors
works if i push this further by going
for an open learning slash distance
learning course how much further do you
think i need to go to make it worthwhile
for context i left school in 1997.
i don't think the year that you left
school is relevant there's not been such
important
developments in mathematics that you
need them to understand most of modern
physics but you know i think this i
think that this question is equivalent
to saying you know what are the basic
pieces of mathematics you really need to
get more out of physics it depends of
course on the kind of physics you're
talking about like most physics
goes very very far with enough calculus
to understand vectors and differential
equations and complex numbers those
three things right once you understand
complex analysis
vector calculus and solving differential
equations especially partial
differential equations then you can do
the vast majority of modern physics
including much of quantum mechanics
there's little bits and pieces you need
to know so for quantum mechanics you
might need a little bit more linear
algebra and things like that but still
solving the differential equations is
the most important thing and that's a
subset of calculus it's the kind of
thing you might only begin to get to
in your first year-long calculus course
in undergraduate so if you're an
undergraduate physics major you take a
year of calculus when you get there and
you're just beginning to think about
solving partial differential equations
and and very often you will take other
courses later on in your second or third
year or whatever that either
are
focused courses about solving
differential equations one way or the
other or
other courses like electromagnetism or
quantum mechanics where
as part of the curriculum you learn more
about solving differential equations so
that's the single most important piece
of mathematical technology for being a
working physicist and then if you want
to get more advanced
string theory or gravity or whatever you
might need to know more pieces but then
usually you learn them as part of the
physics right because they're not shared
among everyone like many physicists
don't need to know tensors because they
just don't need them for the kind of
physics they're doing if you want to do
general relativity you do need to know
tensors and everyone knows that so every
general relativity book teaches you
tensors they don't assume that you know
tensors ahead of time because you
probably don't likewise string theory
will teach you the right kinds of
differential and algebraic geometry and
topology that you need to know string
theory uh statistical mechanics books
will teach you about probability and and
so forth so it's i don't think you need
to that much math but it's like a year
and a half of good solid college level
math will get you a very solid grounding
for things
sid huff says no one would reasonably
deny that einstein was right about a lot
of things what is your credence that he
will eventually be shown to be right
about quantum theory i.e that is somehow
incomplete and when the missing pieces
are found it will consign both the
copenhagen interpretation as well as the
de broglie bone pilot wave theory the
ever
ah ever ready in many worlds
interpretation cubism to the dustbin of
scientific history
well i think that
it's a little bit wrong to contrast
einstein with those
things with the debris boom the boy bomb
pilot wave theory everett cubism because
einstein wasn't around to see them he
didn't have opinions about them okay so
i think that einstein was right to rail
against copenhagen and say that
copenhagen was incomplete but copenhagen
is terrible everyone knows that
there are modern copenhagenists but they
try to improve it they try to fix it up
to make it more respectable but the
other things you're mentioning
especially de broibe and everett those
are well-posed scientific theories
they're different than the sort of
slap-dash set of income coherent rules
that the copenhagen interpretation gives
you
so um
one or more of them might be right but i
don't think you can say that einstein
was complaining about them because he
wouldn't have complained about them he
might have preferred one to the other he
might have liked some aspects of them
and not others so john bell very
famously when he was uh talking about
bowman mechanics and he was a fan of
bowman mechanics and he you know
knew that bohmian mechanics was
compatible with the bell inequality
rules that quantum mechanics has and he
points out that you know einstein had
this worry that he put forward in the
epr paper about spooky action at a
distance and booming mechanics
completely resolves that worry as bell
says
but in the way that einstein would have
liked the least
by basically buying into non-locality uh
the the way that the quantum particles
respond to the wave function is
non-local there you go what are you
going to do
the everettian version of course is
deterministic and it's local within
worlds etc but non-local more generally
but it denies the primacy of space-time
right space-time exists within the
worlds not worlds existing within space
time so einstein would not have liked
that either but who knows what he
actually would have done uh when if
actually faced with these theories
because we do not have that actual
historical event to look at
richard graff says
in the august ama you discussed a
controversy in naming of the webb
telescope given allegations that webb
participated in anti-lgbt activities in
the 1950s 60s
a point not made was that the amount of
time and cultural shift between his
alleged activity and now
but there is a more complex argument
around how much we should project our
current values on actions so long ago
both chronologically and culturally what
is your perspective on this latter
argument for both the web controversy
and in general um i think there's a lot
of complicated questions here
you know one is
don't go too far in the other direction
in pretending that people
in the 1950s and 60s were all terrible
bigots
there were plenty of people in 1950s and
60s who tried very hard to campaign for
lgbt
rights
and there was people against them it was
like an ongoing conversation so it's not
like everyone had that kind of feeling
and the other thing is that some people
might have had private feelings but
didn't act on them and maybe their
private feelings are ones that we
wouldn't have agreed with now but it's
an entirely other level to go out there
and make an effort to make life worse
for lgbt people and others and so i
think that kind of thing is worth
condemning you know i think that slave
owners at a time when slave ownership
was common
still are worthy of condemnation okay
because that's that was wrong and there
were still people in the abolitionist
movement even hundreds of years ago who
were pointing out the opposite
um and again as i said in last month's
ama
the choice of attaching someone's name
to a telescope is
entirely to honor them that's what it's
for right it's not to remember something
historically or whatever
it is a it is a reward in some sense and
if that is a big part of your legacy
then i i completely get
that the argument that that's not
someone we should be honoring and
rewarding and again and again again as i
said last month i don't have an informed
opinion about how involved james webb
was with those controversies to the
extent that i've seen arguments for and
against them it seems to me that he was
but i'm not an expert historian
i do not have not read the original
documents etc i think that should be in
the hands of other people to do that
carefully you know universities like
both caltech and johns hopkins in recent
years have done that they have sat down
and said look we have a lot of things
named after a lot of people who maybe
did some bad things should we change the
names of things and it's not that hard
yeah just do it if you turn out to be
terrible people change the names right
caltech's tallest building is the
library building right in the center of
campus and it was named after robert
milliken a very famous
very uh accomplished physicist turns out
i mean it's not turns out it's been
known for a long time he was a huge
eugenicist and racist like being a
eugenicist and trying to depress the
reproductive rate of other races and
people he considered inferior was a
really big part of his life
and so they decided that that was not
the kind of person they wanted to honor
naming the library after him anymore and
they changed the name of the library not
a big deal and i think it's a perfectly
sensible thing to do
rob patro says this is a bit out of the
blue but i've not heard you talk much
about the subject and i'm quite curious
about your take given your background
what do you think about p versus np
for example do you think that p is not
equal to np what evidence for against it
do you find most compelling and do you
think we'll see a proof so p versus np
is the question of
complexity classes of computational
problems uh p is the set of problems
that you can
solve in a relatively short period of
time and np problems are those that
whose solutions you can check if you're
given the solution to them you can check
that it's the right solution in a short
period of time
um
all sensible people think that these are
not the same complexity classes that p
does not equal np in other words to to
think that p is not equal to np
is to say i think there are some
problems that are hard to solve but it's
easy to check the solution for to say
that they are
equal as complexity classes is to say
that there are no problems that are hard
to solve for which we can also check the
solution easily and most problems when
you're given the solution you can check
it whether
it's a good solution or not right
um
but we haven't proven it yet
so people worry
whenever we think something is true but
we haven't proven it i mean this is why
this is the charm and beauty of
mathematics right that it's not going to
settle for
our fuzzy intuitions says you gotta
prove things and so as long as we
haven't proven it um then it's still an
open question and you shouldn't be super
duper sure
but there are you know good reasons to
think things are true even if we haven't
proven them yet uh scott is a scott
aronson is a much better person than i
am to go on about this and you can read
his blog writings about it all of the
things that would be
uh very easy to do in a world where p
equals np that we think are hard to do
right
uh aximitizing creativity and things
like that um again maybe that's all
possible but it just seems very wrong to
us and so
i have no reason whatsoever to think
that p is equal to np i i see lots of
reasons to think it's not so i'm going
to go with that until there's good
evidence otherwise
as far as when we'll see a proof i have
no idea whatsoever uh might take a long
while there's no deadline on this
there's no ticking clock it takes how
long it however long it takes
sandra pagliani says when the math says
that a black hole's store of information
is measured by its surface area does
that mean that the black hole's surface
is where the information is stored at
the horizon
yeah good question
so no it doesn't mean that necessarily
so it doesn't mean that logically it
doesn't follow as an implication that
just because that's how much information
it's stored
in the black hole means that that's
where it's stored right you can
certainly imagine alternatives but on
the other hand it's certainly
provocative certainly suggested maybe
something like that is true
and so the modern view of holography and
complementarity is that there are
different ways of thinking about where
the information is in the black hole and
there's no fundamental answer to the
question where the information is stored
from the perspective of a far away
observer outside the black hole it is as
if the information is stored at the
horizon
from the perspective of someone falling
into the black hole it is as if the
information is spread across the volume
inside because different observers see
different things that's a very common
thing in quantum mechanical setups uh we
did talk about this a little bit with
lenny suskin when he was on the podcast
and without being too revealing we'll
have another podcast talking about
similar things very soon
brent meeker says in your conversation
with william mccaskill you switch back
and forth referring to ethics and
morality as though they were
interchangeable i think that it is one
of the advances of the enlightenment
that they were distinguished that there
is a domain of private virtue distinct
from public virtue the latter is
dominated by rule utilitarianism because
society must be persuaded that the rules
are good for them but private virtue was
separated by the wall between church and
state the church has never admitted this
separation so do you agree to this
distinction if so where is the line
drawn
well i agree there are plenty of
distinctions one can draw i do not agree
that it maps on immediately and
universally to the words ethics and
morality if you talk to people who are
philosophers specializing in ethics and
morality you know if you put a couple of
drinks into them and they will admit
that usually these words are used
interchangeably there's maybe a slight
difference of connotation
in the sense that ethics kind of refers
to rules and morality might be more
private sure
but very very often these are used
completely interchangeably and so in
that podcast we were just not being very
careful we were using them
interchangeably
kunal menda says testimonies of
near-death experiences describe them as
almost psychedelic why do you think
humans have near-death experiences is
there a way evolution by natural
selection could have had a mechanism to
select for them
well i don't know if evolution plays a
role here except in the most
tangential way but i'm not going to
speculate on that because i think that
the answer to the prior question is is
pretty easy
near-death experiences are almost by
definition pretty stressful
they are
experiences where things are not going
well for the organism undergoing those
experiences right our guard is down our
resources are failing us our systems are
breaking down okay
and psychedelic experiences are you know
as i did in a blog post long ago i
talked about um the fact that you can
actually
when it comes to
geometric hallucinations like certain
kinds of hallucinations that we see on
psychedelic substances have geometries
and they even classified what kinds you
know some of them look like tunnels some
of them look like spider webs or
whatever and you can actually
reproduce the classification of these
geometric hallucinations just by solving
equations representing
vibrations in the visual cortex okay
and of course the question is not why do
these appear when we do psychedelics or
when we're near death but why don't they
appear all the time if they're just sort
of fundamental vibrations in the visual
cortex
and the answer as uh people who have
studied psychedelics have established
and as far as i understand it i did a
podcast with robin carhart harris you
can go back and check he is an actual
psychedelic researcher
you know the vibrations and lots of
things are going on in our brains all
the time but they don't bubble up to our
conscious perceptions and in part that's
because they get filtered out
so the reasons why you hallucinate when
you're on uh psychedelics it's and so
forth and probably also when you're
having a near-death experience is not
because there is some new visual thing
that pops up but that the barriers
between your conscious perception and
the existing visual things churning
around in the background of your brain
come down okay the barriers are lowered
and so you can experience these things
so it is literally the least surprising
thing to think that near-death
experiences resemble
psychedelic experiences in both cases
our guards are down and we're seeing
things that are going on naturally in
our brains
david maxwell says
in the sub fields closer to your heart
what do who do you think might win nobel
prizes for physics in the coming years
and are there particular people or
theories you think should win if
experimental verification were not so
important
um
so first i should say i don't care
really i don't care who's going to win
the nobel prize i would love to win it
myself except i would be pretty
embarrassed because i clearly have not
done any work deserving of the nobel
prize so when i say i would like to win
it myself what i mean is i would like to
do some work deserving of the nobel
prize
but if that happens honestly and maybe
this is just me blowing smoke but i
think it's true
doing the work
is more important than winning the prize
like if you i don't know if you wrote
down the theory of general relativity
which by the way never won the nobel
prize but if you are the person who
wrote down the theory of gender
relativity that matters more than
winning some prize that people vote on i
mean come on
that's just something no one can take
away from you if you're the person who
figured that out
okay so i don't really care who wins it
having said that i think there's two
areas close to my heart where there's
sort of
good cases to be made for prizes
one is in the foundations of quantum
mechanics right um the last time anyone
won a nobel prize for the foundations of
quantum mechanics was in the 1950s when
max born won it for the probabilistic
interpretation years after he actually
did the probabilistic interpretation uh
but there are stories there and um i
think we've made progress especially in
the last few decades i mean i guess the
few is becoming a larger number now but
we talked already in this ama about
decoherence
and um the fact that we understand the
phenomenon of entanglement and the
technological ramifications and how to
use it much better than we used to
um
and that could be involved in a nobel
prize given to all sorts of different
people zurich might be one of them i
don't i don't feel any groundswell for
that so i'm not going to vote i'm not
going to place bets that that's going to
happen but i'd be very happy if it did a
nobel prize for decoherence or pointer
states
um also in the quantum realm quantum
computing quantum algorithms peter shore
charles bennett people like that right a
whole new wonderful field that has
opened up over the last few years um and
other fundamental quantum things like
the aaron of bone effect right yakirino
was still around and would be a very no
very uh worthy nobel prize winner
the other area that's obvious is we did
discover the higgs boson and we
immediately gave prizes to the theorists
who helped uh invent the idea which is
good which is fine which is great but
the experimentalists deserve some credit
there too they are the ones who put
their lives uh to the effort of actually
finding it of course we all know what
the problem there is the nobel committee
has made up a rule where it can only be
given to three people at a time and
thousands of people worked on finding
the higgs boson there were specific
individuals who gave the talks but
that's not because they were necessarily
the most important people in uh the
actual discoveries they were the
spokespeople for the collaborations at
that moment in time and they're
world-class great physicists so i
wouldn't complain if they won the nobel
prize but
it's hard to reconcile giving it to them
without giving it to all their
colleagues
i would be very much in favor of
changing the rules so that big
collaborations can win the prize but no
one's asking me about that the other
thing to do is to give it to people who
built the lhc right that's an enormous
technological
achievement and i think that lynn evans
for example whose story i talk about in
my book the particle at the end of the
universe uh arguably the single person
who did more than anyone else to guide
the lhc to its eventual successful
status
would be a wonderful choice of nobel
prize winner
tim gianitos says you argued in last
month's ama that it takes just as much
causal sense i just had to check that
wasn't casual sense causal sense
to say the past is responsible for the
present as it does to say the present is
responsible for the past i wonder if
some similar reasoning can be applied to
bottom-up empiricism versus top-down
scientists are generally bottom-up we
think what's really going on is quantum
phenomena and so all macro phenomena
could be reduced to complicated particle
interactions but isn't it equally
legitimate to say that what's really
going on is personal agency fluid
dynamics and the economy and that the
quantum world must be the way it is
because of them
so first i think i want to clarify the
beginning of the question because you
say
that i said it makes as much causal
sense to say the past is responsible for
the present as it does to say the
president is responsible for the past
um that's not true that's that's not
true without qualification the
qualification needs to put on is that's
true in the context of reversible
microphysical dynamics okay so if we're
really working at the level of classical
newtonian mechanics or the schrodinger
equation or any other purportedly exact
fundamental description that has
reversible dynamics in it
then
it makes just as much sense to say past
is responsible for the future or the
present as it does vice versa because
everything's reversible information is
conserved from moment to moment but
very often we are not working at that
level in the everyday level where we
coarse grain and have macro states and
things are not reversible it does not
make just as much sense to say that
causes come after effects as before them
that would not make any sense there are
good reasons why
in the everyday world causes precedent
effects so that's one thing to say
then to your actual question um about
top down versus bottom up
no
i do not agree that similar reasoning
can be applied to bottom-up empiricism
versus top down because the
relationship between the microscopic
theories we're talking about in the
macroscopic theories is very much one
way
it's a relationship of throwing away
information
if i give you the positions and
velocities of all of the atoms in a
planet
i can calculate its center of mass and
its center of mass momentum
but if i give you the center of mass
location and center of mass momentum i
cannot calculate the positions and
velocities of all those particles right
it's a irreversible mapping it's a very
very one-way process
in fact there is what we call multiple
realizability um given any set of
macroscopic phenomena we can imagine all
sorts of different microscopic phenomena
that could give rise to them so it is
not equally legitimate to say that
what's really going on is personal
agency etc and the quantum world must be
the way it is because of them
i mean for many thousands of years we
talked about personal agency and fluid
dynamics without knowing there was such
a thing as quantum mechanics right you
cannot derive quantum mechanics from a
human
agency or anything like that
john jon says i'm wondering about the
possible amplitudes of gravity waves is
it possible to create a gravity wave so
strong that its troughs are temporarily
black holes or conversely to have it
crest so high that light could escape a
black hole so um yes
except with for a footnote and no uh so
it is possible to make a gravity wave so
strong that it forms a black hole
but it's not going to be temporary black
holes are not temporary i mean of course
they eventually evaporate away but
putting aside that completely separate
effect in the context of classical
general relativity once you make a black
hole it's forever and that's true in
gravitational waves also of course if a
single gravitational wave is just
propagating along then it either is or
is not a black hole
but if you have two gravitational waves
with strong amplitudes and they
intersect each other then maybe you get
enough stretching of space time that you
make a black hole that's completely
plausible
could it have a crest so high that light
could escape a black hole no light
cannot escape black holes otherwise
otherwise we would have told you about
that sorry
vladimir bellic says how will higher
education evolve over the next few
decades in your estimation nowadays in
the information age more and more people
choose to self-study instead of going to
college because they're able to learn
those same skills in the internet
practically for free for instance
you know i don't know like people are
asking me a lot of these questions i
apologize to people who ask me questions
about my idea of what the future will
hold uh you know i try i don't always
succeed but i try to limit things that i
say
even in these amas to things that either
i believe are strongly true
or things that i you know know as much
as anyone else does and therefore at
least have an informed opinion um but
something like this i don't know you
know it's certainly the case
that things are changing um the internet
has made lots of things accessible that
were not accessible before
but
i don't think that there's any simple
replacement of online education for
in-person education i'm a huge believer
in online education i love online
courses i think more people should take
them i love the fact that it's made
high-level knowledge much more
accessible than it ever has been and i
predict that it will continue to grow in
importance on the other hand it's not a
replacement there are other things that
ordinary in-person education does that
online education doesn't
many of the interactions many of the
important roles played by going to
college are socialization roles you know
meeting people from different
environments talking to them getting to
know different ways of being in the
world or different backgrounds or
whatever the informal conversations you
have at breakfast before going to class
can be crucially crucially important
sitting down with friends to do problem
sets or whatever just going out and
socializing dating you know there's many
many roles
that are played in those crucial years
from when you're 18 to 22 years old
that really happen in person on a campus
in ways it's not the only way to make
them happen of course there are plenty
of ways to grow up and mature as a
person that do not involve going to
college but it's not the same going to
campus and being on campus as just
taking some online courses
um the other thing of course is that
the
there's a credentialing aspect right so
you can do this online or
in person but
a college education is more than just
learning things
for me learning things is the most
important thing but let's not fool
ourselves there's also being able to say
i have gotten some skills and i can now
use those skills in the real world and
that is important for being hired and
going on forward in your life so
learning things will always be important
but also being able to say i got a
degree will always matter therefore
i don't know how it will all play out
going forward
hopefully it will make things more
flexible and more accessible to a wider
set of people but
i don't see any end to the existing
system where people
to a large extent go to college for four
years and take classes
at a physical location
brendan hall says an annoyed asher perez
once said at a conference in response to
a quantum interpretation poll who here
believes that the laws of physics are
decided by a democratic vote
being a mini-worlder myself this made me
sad and angry that this very smart
physicist could be opposed to discussion
of interpretations but especially his
opposition to a simple poll of opinions
how can this attitude still be so strong
in physics well there's two different
attitudes being mixed up here
one both of which i think are bad so i'm
on your side
one is just being against the idea of
discussing quantum interpretations or
foundations of quantum mechanics or
different approaches to quantum
foundations i think i i mean i'm not
going to spend a lot of time amplifying
that if you listen to this podcast you
know what i think about that i wrote a
book i've done many podcasts about it i
think it's it's important
it is still a very strong attitude in
physics but i think it's gradually
declining i think things are getting
better to be honest the other is this
attitude that you know we shouldn't take
an opinion poll because that's not how
the laws of physics are decided
no duh that's not how the laws of
physics are decided guess what when we
do an opinion poll about you know who
should win the election the result of
that opinion poll does not actually
decide the election we actually have to
go out and vote so even in the most
heavily uh polled things we all know
there's a distinction between deciding
and polling people
i think it's interesting to poll people
and to ask them questions and to get
their opinions about things it's there's
even something a recent concept that i
learned uh from kevin zulman who's a
philosopher
uh the concept is called pluralistic
ignorance
and it's it's basically the emperor's
new clothes or the emperor has no
clothes um yeah the emperor's new groove
is what i'm thinking of the emperor has
no clothes right the story where
everyone is reluctant to point out that
the emperor is not wearing any clothes
and one reason is because they think all
of their friends see the clothes right
and pluralistic ignorance is when you're
reluctant to say what you actually
believe because you believe everyone
else believes something different and
will think badly about you but it's not
true they actually all think the same
thing and they themselves are not saying
it out loud because they think that
everyone disagrees with them
this is a real phenomenon and it can
cause harm and so i think that
talking to people getting rough ideas
about how many people believe different
things this is a hugely useful thing
philosophers are much less fussy about
this right i mean they have the
wonderful
project by david chalmers and david
bourget i think his name is on what
philosophers believe
and
if you are a professional philosopher
and you you sign up for phil people.org
so it's just a list of all the
philosophers right and
what one wonderful charming thing about
this site is that mostly it's a way to
link to your papers and your website but
they also ask you to tell them what your
philosophical views are so you can say
like i'm a naturalist i'm a
compatibilist about free will i'm a
determinist or whatever right and they
and then you can list them and you can
say i don't have any opinion about
things you don't have any opinions about
but it's a nice way to get a general
feeling for where people land nothing
wrong with that in the real world of
human beings
oleg ruvinsky says the great polish
sci-fi writer stanislav lem devoted a
lot of his works to the problem of
contact between human and alien
intelligence even when both sides
recognize each other as such he claimed
that the different evolutionary paths
that each
took makes any kind of meaningful
contact or comprehension almost income
impossible have you read some of his
later works like fiasco and what do you
think about the idea in general i've
read some of his works not fiasco i'm
certainly not an expert
i really don't have any idea about this
very important question you know we've
had a few
um
podcasts lately about evolutionary
biology here on earth and the question
of convergence versus divergence the
role of contingency and randomness as
would be championed by my namesake sean
b carroll versus the role of convergence
as other people who've been on more
recently would talk about
um but that's number one
here on earth and number two mostly
about biological morphology not about
cognitive capacities or ways of thinking
so to be very honest i can absolutely
see both sides to this one
i can see that you know
the way that different species develop
intelligence
let's imagine the following argument the
way that different species develop
intelligence is more or less in response
to similar problems and more or less in
the presence of similar resources to
solve them right
so therefore it would not be surprising
if they developed more or less similar
strategies and tools for doing it and
therefore maybe the kinds of thinking
and cognition and consciousness that
alien creatures have is even if it's
different in details still recognizable
and familiar to us and something that we
could meaningfully communicate with
that's a perfectly legitimate argument
here's another argument we only know one
way to be
advanced technological highly
intelligent creatures namely the way
that we do it here on earth right
in principle there could be a huge
number of different ways to be those
kinds of creatures we don't know we've
only literally have one data point so we
should be humble and recognize that
there could be many other ways that we
haven't thought of because we're not
that smart to be intelligent and to uh
communicate with each other and
therefore when we meet an alien the
smart money says we probably will have
enormous difficulty understanding them
i don't know i think both of those are
very reasonable arguments honestly so i
would love to
i would love to hear
better arguments for and against it and
you know one of the things is i this is
an area where for reasons i don't
understand when i do talk to people who
have strong opinions
about these things about the nature of
aliens uh and alien life and
civilizations
they always seem really
biased one way or the other like they
seem to have reasons why
they believe what they're saying is
likely to be true about alien organisms
or or beings
for reasons other than a cold rational
discussion of the scientific
possibilities so i haven't heard a lot
of
discussion about this kind of thing that
is persuasive to me i mean to be
persuasive to me would both have to be
informed and you know thinking carefully
about both of those sides of the
argument that i both that i just put
forward and to really sort of go through
the details right i mean when i when i
say out loud oh there's many ways of of
thinking
what does that mean how many ways of
thinking are there you know i don't know
what that means exactly to be much more
careful about it would be required or on
the other side if you're saying well
you're going to converge to the same
thing well prove it or at least give me
an argument for it like show me this
convergence in thought space uh and the
necessity of it i don't know it's very
hard so i'm not surprised that no one
has a very very strong convincing answer
even though some people think they do um
but i think it's a good question to
think about
p walder says can abstract ideas have a
causal effect on the material world
well
guess what that depends it depends on
what you mean by having a causal effect
so
if i needed to give a one word answer
the answer would be yes
um but i need to explain what that means
when you talk about causal effects you
need to have a theory of causality right
you have to theory what that means and
so
i in my personal way of thinking about
cause and effect relations i don't talk
about them at all at the microphysical
reversible level i don't think the cause
effect relations are the right way of
thinking about newtonian mechanics or
the schrodinger equation or anything
like that i think that cause effect
relations are emergent phenomena at a
higher level of description where you
have irreversible dynamics an arrow of
time
randomness and unpredictability etc okay
and so in that world in the higher level
emergent world can abstract ideas have a
causal effect means
when you're trying to successfully
describe the behavior of the things in
that higher level emergent description
is it important and useful and
relevant to include abstract ideas in
the set of things that in the set of
degrees of freedom if you want to put it
that way so not only do i say here is a
set of people
with certain body types and ages and
locations in space and they're
interacting in the following room but
also
some of the people have the following
abstract ideas in their head and other
people have different abstract ideas in
their head well guess what
yes those abstract ideas are going to
have a hugely important causal effect
they help understand what's going on you
know like this person uh sacrificed
himself because of a feeling of
patriotism
is that a meaningful sentence yeah i
think it is
uh or or motherhood or
you know whatever uh different reasons
why you might think that there's certain
moral obligations or ethical rules or
whatever these are all abstract ideas
and
they absolutely play a crucial role in
our best understanding of the
macroscopic human scale world this is
basically exactly the argument i give
for believing in compatibilist free will
our best understanding our best theory
our best way of describing actual human
beings is as agents making choices i
don't see any way around that if you had
a better theory then good tell me what
that theory is tell me a way of
predicting what human beings can do that
does not involve them making choices
then that would be great then good for
you but i haven't seen that theory
likewise i think that our best theory of
talking about the actions of human
beings includes abstract ideas in their
head as some of the degrees of freedom
that you need to include
paul hess says the higgs boson seems
unique among all other particles as
having no charge and no spin is there
some deeper significance to this
uniqueness
maybe
but i think it sort of goes the other
way around
so here's what i think that most modern
field theorists would say
there's no problem whatsoever in
inventing
fields and corresponding particles that
have no charge and no spin neutral
spinless bosons it's easy to write those
down i mean cosmologists make a living
doing this the inflaton field is one
that is supposed to have no charge and
no spin for example
um
but the higgs boson is the only one that
we found and you you notice it was hard
to find right we didn't find it first we
knew about electrons and photons long
before we do about the higgs boson why
is that anyway
the rough answer is that there is
kind of a natural scale
in known physics in the core theory
given by the planck scale the scale at
which quantum gravitational effects
might become important and that scale is
very very high very very energetic
compared to
the masses of particles that we know
about
but the way you think about that in
modern physics is
not oh my goodness the planck scale is
so big but oh my goodness the masses and
energies of most of physics are so tiny
compared to the playing scale how can we
make sense of that
and the answer is for almost every
particle
there are symmetries that keep the
masses of these particles low
gauge invariants in electromagnetism
keeps the mass of the photon zero
similarly something very similar for the
gluon of qcd and the graviton of gravity
um
there are what are called chiral
symmetries that help keep the masses of
the fermions low so the mass of the
electron the mass of the quarks etc are
kept low
and both of those symmetries the
existence of both of those symmetries
depend on the spin of the particles okay
not the charge really the charges it
plays a semi-related role but the spin
is really really important so the spin
one-half fermions and the spin-one gauge
bosons both have a natural way to keep
their masses lower than the planck scale
the higgs boson since it's a scalar
particle does not have any known
symmetry that keeps its mass low so
there is a mystery
why is the mass of the higgs boson so
low okay so
the question is you know why is there
only one particle that has no charge and
no spin uh the real question is why is
there even one particle that we've been
able to discover i mean maybe there's
lots of particles up near near the
planck scale but they have masses up
near the plank scale that's the natural
thing
the fact that the mass of the higgs
boson is so low compared to the planck
scale is a famous problem it is called
the hierarchy problem in particle
physics and we don't know the answer to
it we have many suggestions on the table
uh and this was the there's sort of a a
general version and a specific version
of what we expected to see at the large
hadron collider the lhc like you'll
often read that people are very
optimistic about finding super symmetry
at the lhc
uh and i'm speaking in the past tense
but it's still possible we do however
it's absolutely it could have been
possible we would have already and we
didn't yet um
and the reason why is because
supersymmetry
offers an explanation for why the mass
of the higgs boson is so small
supersymmetry can be that symmetry that
protects the higgs boson from getting a
mass
and even if it wasn't supersymmetry we
really thought there would be something
else
near the electroweak scale where the
higgs mass is located that would explain
why it's not more massive and there
isn't anything so we would we thought
that the hierarchy problem gave us a
good reason to think that we would
discover new particles at the lhc and of
course again maybe we will tomorrow but
uh we haven't yet and that's that's a
big puzzle so that's the deep
significance that there is a puzzle we
don't know the answer to
which is why is the higgs boson mass so
low that we actually have a chance of
seeing it in particle accelerators
wells burrell says
do you have any major ethical concerns
about the gene editing revolution other
than germline editing of human embryos
and if so what are they do you believe
that gene editing is a positive
technology which will deliver on the
hype what kind of future do you think is
realistic here so again what kind of
future thing going on here about in an
area where i have no expertise
whatsoever
um except for you know the ethical
things i have a little bit of expertise
there uh after all i am now a
philosopher officially credentialed
uh so
i think i have fewer ethical concerns
than the average person i think that a
lot of people's ethical concerns about
gene editing arise from a feeling of
ickiness
that you know
peop you know
that genes that we go in there and alter
are somehow less legitimate or natural
or okay than ones that randomly bump
into each other during the ordinary
course of sexual reproduction
i think that's kind of a false
distinction so i don't feel that very
much
i think the more important thing to say
is i think it's going to happen
i i'm not someone who thinks like there
seems to be a bunch of people who think
we can just
write down rules and stop gene editing
from happening in human beings i think
that's just hopelessly unrealistic it's
going to happen somebody's going to do
it it's actually not that hard remember
the
the podcast we did with theodore ornov
who says oh yeah you know it's going to
happen in people's garages
so not only are other countries going to
do it who might not feel the same way as
us but even individuals in any one
country will be able to do it
and there's a lot of obvious good things
to do you know if you can prevent babies
from
having diseases or whatever ahead of
time knowing that stop them from
suffering i think that's just good i
think we should just do it and then if
you could also make them smarter and
stronger and healthier
i think you know why not i i don't see
the problem with that i don't think that
necessarily leads to any gattica
stepford wives i don't know what the
worry that you had that you might have
uh is
um so i think it's gonna happen i think
it's probably less bad than a lot of
people worry about
having said all that there are obvious
problems uh that you can go into maybe
people start editing genes to be
something other than simply making
babies healthier and and stronger or
whatever
maybe they make them worse rather than
better uh maybe they want to eliminate
certain kinds of human beings that exist
now in the world oh that would be very
very bad
so i kind of think that the current
that in some sense maybe it's a little
bit unfair but my rough untutored
feeling is that the current state of
discourse about these things is pretty
primitive and and not really taking the
problems and the potentials nearly
seriously enough it's just sort of
acting uh on the basis of ickiness and
let's not change anything because
natural
behaviors are better um i don't think
that's realistic or good but i do think
that there are concerns and worries that
are important and so we should be taking
those concerns and worries more
carefully even if i'm not enough of an
expert to tell you what the biggest
concerns and worries actually are
shred cadmium says
temperature is defined as the mean
kinetic energy of a system in my view
this concept doesn't have a direct
equivalent in quantum theory because the
mean and system bits while representing
something entirely real are only
appropriate to a macro level of
description
my friend thinks i'm wrong is he right
so i do think you're wrong
but i think you're wrong for a subtle
reason that i'm getting from reading in
between the lines of your question and i
could be completely misreading here so
sorry if i'm misinterpreting
but you seem to be
contrasting quantum theory
versus macro level of description and i
think that's an inappropriate
distinction to draw the difference is
between quantum and classical
and micro and macro but those are two
different sets of distinction
quantum systems can be macroscopic
there's no problem with that or let's
say there can be macroscopic systems
that we choose to describe using the
rules of quantum mechanics no problem at
all so if you go back to the podcast i
recently did with nicole younger halpern
the whole subject she studies is quantum
thermodynamics
you need to have a temperature to talk
about thermodynamics at least in
equilibrium you have a temperature in
non-equilibrium situations things get
more complicated but there is absolutely
no problem in defining the temperature
of a quantum system in equilibrium
i mean there are explicit formulas for
it so it's it's very very common and
very very frequent that we talk about
quantum many-body systems that are uh
macroscopic you know defend the
definition of macroscopic but have
enough particles or whatever in them
that we find it useful to not describe
them particle by particle but
collectively and in those cases
temperature is a 100 useful quantum
uh
parameter
andrew goldstein says any thoughts as to
why human vision is limited to
electromagnetic wavelengths of roughly
400 to 700 nanometers i've read that
insects can see ultraviolet light and
birds can sense magnetic fields well yes
i hope that you've not only read that
but heard it discussed in the recent
podcast with ed young that's exactly
what he was talking about
the fact that many different animal
species have many different sensory
capacities that we human beings don't so
i don't know
specifically the reason why that's the
range of human vision obviously it is
the most obviously useful range because
it is the visibility the transparency of
the atmosphere so it is the part of the
sun's light that gets to us here on
earth but you can imagine it would also
be useful even if perhaps not as
directly useful to see infrared light
because that's sort of the thing that
living beings give off through their
heat radiation and maybe even
ultraviolet light i don't know um
but what you have to keep in mind is all
these capacities have costs associated
with them right so
you know evolution happens as a very
delicate balancing act between many
different constraints
we take an energy we put that energy to
use one of the reasons why humans are so
different than other animals is that we
have a much greater percentage of our
energy budget devoted to our brains the
human brain is a tremendous energy
eater up that's not the best word
consumer
and so why would you ever do that why
would you waste so much energy that
could be used for running and jumping
away from your prey or whatever i guess
toward your prey away from your
predators
rather than just using it for thinking
right and the answer is there turns out
to be some usefulness in being able to
think but you need to have the kind of
niche ecologically where it is more
useful to put that energy into thinking
than it was and to put that putting that
energy into running and jumping and
maybe those
those niches are kind of rare
i can imagine that similar
considerations work for
vision so you know it's again it's not
just some solid-state apparatus where
you program into the human eye what it's
sensitive to you build the human eye out
of chemicals and out of specific
configurations of biochemical processes
that happen when the photons of light
hit the rods and cones in your eyes
maybe in order to see other wavelengths
you would need to add on more chemical
superstructure into your eyes and that
would cost resources and either energy
or
just sort of chemical instructions or
whatever and it turns out not to be
worth it right all of evolution and all
biological design is a set of
compromises so you can't just say why
don't we have this ability you have to
say what would it cost to get that
ability and is it really worth it
sandro stuckey says your discussion with
bill mccaskill on long-termism made me
think about how one can increase one's
confidence in predictions about the
long-term future
i remember that climate scientists
evaluate their models by running them in
the past and comparing their results
against historical data but this seems
really hard when it comes to predictions
about the impact of human choices i'm
struggling to come up with examples of
historical decisions for which we can
say with certainty that they improved or
worsened the present e.g we probably
needed the industrial revolution to go
to today's high standard of living but
it also resulted in climate change etc
are there historical decisions that
impact us today and that you wish had
been taken earlier or not been taken at
all
so i guess sandro you're that was a a
twisty question that ended up in a
different place than i thought you were
going
uh i mean so let me say what i wanted to
respond to at the beginning of the
question which is i agree
um it is difficult to have high
confidence and predictions about the
long-term future there are too many
variables you know society and life and
the earth's ecosystem are all highly
nonlinear systems with lots of
possibilities for unanticipated
consequences at the same time we need to
have opinions about what is likely we
need to have credences okay you can't
just have a know-nothing attitude that
says well it's hard therefore i don't
care
you have to do your best even if your
best is not very very good so that's
where i thought you were going with the
question but what you're actually going
is are there historical condition
decisions that you wish had been taken
earlier or not been taken at all i mean
sure
in retrospect i wish we'd put tight
controls on spewing fossil fuels into
the
fossil fuel remnants relics gases
uh into the air a lot longer ago because
climate change is a big problem i wish
we hadn't done the holocaust right that
was a bad decision
i don't want to you know make light of
all the terrible historical tragedies
that occurred that i wish hadn't
happened but
some of them were human decisions right
so i think it's easy to say like the
industrial revolution had both good
consequences and bad consequences when
you go at that grand scope of
event
they will always have both good advances
and bad advances religion
science these have had both positive
consequences and negative consequences i
think we nevertheless need to
weigh them right i mean maybe you could
say that between the year zero and the
year fifteen hundred
religion had mostly good consequences or
maybe not i don't know
and maybe you could also say after 1500
had mostly bad consequences but you have
to try right i mean you have to i i
don't have a list of historical
decisions that are tricky and i have a
different opinion about than other
people
but i do think that
you can't duck the question right i mean
you do have to sit down and think about
it going forward for history you conduct
the question you could ignore that
question if you wanted to but going
forward even if you're talking about
things which will have both positive and
negative consequences
you either do that thing or you don't
and so you have to decide the best you
can whether it's going to be net
positive or net negative to the best of
your ability
maxine says i've recently heard that a
good way for a layperson to understand
gravity and general relativity is that
gravitational time dilation is what
causes the gravity we experience here on
earth
the explanation is that one can imagine
a falling person with a clock on its
head and a clock on its feet ticking at
different rates
this time gradient is said to rotate the
object's motion arrow aka 4 velocity
more and more toward the earth and this
is what we experience as gravity it
seems pretty amazing in at least an
apparent sense of being intuitive is
this a good way for a lay person to
understand
the fascinating but intimidating inner
workings of general relativity
well i'm going to take a wishy-washy
stance toward this question i think it's
a good question it's a good question to
think about and ask um here is what i
worry about so
so actually i don't know is the short i
don't even know if the if this
explanation is correct
it sounds like the kind of thing that
could very well be correct and probably
was come up with come up with by someone
who knew what they were talking about
okay but i haven't sat down and thought
about it i mean i know the equations the
geodesic equation that we use that we
actually solve to
show what the motion of particles is in
a curved space time or people for that
matter
and then what you can try to do is say
that rather than just telling people
don't worry things move on geodesics you
can try to be a little bit more
clear
about
the physicalness behind why the
geodesics take the form they do
having said that there's also a huge
worry in in purported explanations of
this form which is that they give the
illusion of understanding that they put
together a bunch of words that sound
kind of right
and give you the right answer and
therefore you accept them but if you dig
into them more deeply maybe they don't
work as much for the specific
scenario that you just outlined
even if i have a single point
particle that doesn't have a head and a
foot that is just a zero dimensionality
or really really tiny it still falls in
a gravitational field i don't see how i
can relate the clock on its head and the
clock on its feet
to
that kind of motion because it doesn't
it's heading his footer in the same
place it's just a particle right
so i'm not sure that that explanation is
really capturing everything um the the
example i know even better is in
cosmology when we talk about dark energy
and the cosmological constant you will
sometimes hear the following kind of
thing that the cosmological constant has
negative pressure right so a negative
pressure is like a tension so if you had
a box of cosmological constant and zero
cause martial constant outside you can't
do that but if you could the cosmos
constant would pull in on the box and
cause it to squeeze rather than pushing
it out like air in a balloon negative
pressure okay
and this is supposed to be what causes
the universe to accelerate rather than
to
expand ever more slowly because what
we're told is
the
thing that counts for making the
universe accelerate or decelerate is the
energy density plus three times the
pressure
and so if the pressure is large and
negative you get an effectively negative
amount of push
all of those words are individually
correct
but a miracle occurred if i don't know
if you noticed this but who says that
the thing that matters for the expansion
of the universe is pressure plus is is
energy density plus three times the
pressure i mean that just came out of
nowhere right and in fact it's not even
really true if you look at the friedman
equation for the expansion of the
universe it's h squared where h is the
hubble constant is proportional to rho
the energy density there's no mention of
the pressure in that equation there's
another equation for the second
derivative that does involve the
pressure but i don't need that second
equation to solve for to get the entire
accelerating history of the universe and
i think it's just a wrong explanation i
think a better explanation relies on the
fact that dark energy is persistent that
it does not dilute away as the universe
expands i think the negative pressure
thing sort of plays on your intuition
that an uh
pressure
pushes things and well sorry i should
say the other way around
the negative pressure explanation is is
really
bad because people can start thinking
about it and they realize that a
negative pressure is a tension that
pulls things together so why isn't the
negative pressure pulling galaxies
together rather than pushing them apart
and the answer is that the negative
pressure isn't doing anything at all
by itself it's the gravitational effect
of the negative pressure on the
curvature of space-time that is doing
something but anyway
this is what happens when i start
talking about my bet noirs my my own um
hot button issues here uh you didn't
care about that what you what you cared
about is this completely different
attempt to understand why objects fall
in general relativity so the short
answer is i don't know whether this is a
good explanation or not but i would be
aware and cautious
about purported explanations that make
you feel good without actually making
you completely understand what is going
on
anthony familaro says i'm afraid you
triggered a touch of ptsd in me with
your bigfoot story in the last ama i'm a
couple of years younger than you and
when i was a child the documentary i
believe you were talking about was
heavily advertised on tv
every time the ad appeared i ran
screaming from the room and was
terrified for hours afterward just to
verify that it was the same documentary
do you remember whether there was a
scene in which
someone was sitting calmly on a couch
only to have bigfoot's huge arm crash
through the window next to him and
violently grab a table lamp i'm afraid
that just googling it would be too much
for my heart
so um
i don't know probably yes like what
you're describing is completely
consistent with my memories but i do not
actually remember that particular scene
um i do remember that the documentary
was scary and so it's completely
compatible like i said that that scene
was there uh but no i don't want to
google it either honestly like
time is short i don't want to re-live my
childhood traumas i'm not afraid of
bigfoot anymore by the way but you know
who knows i mean maybe googling would
change that all right i'm going to
group together two questions about the
past hypothesis and the big bang eric
strongquist says i'm interested in any
comments you have on why the truth of
the past hypothesis
is taken to be surprising or unexpected
i understand that if the initial
microstate of the universe was drawn
from some probability distribution of
microstates in phase space
then that state would likely correspond
to a higher entropy macrostate because
higher entropy macrostates occupy most
of the phase space by definition
but why do we assume if we do that there
should be such a random distribution
meaning that the big bang shouldn't
produce some especially simple
symmetrical or unique state which may
correspond to a low entropy macro
description the big bang is after all a
pretty special event
and then mike brock says
i often heard it said that the big bang
did not happen at a point in space and
that it is a moment in time it is also
said that the big bang happened
everywhere at once i conceptually get
this but one question i have is that at
the incident of the big bang did the
universe have a spatial extent at all so
these questions are about different
things but they feed into each other and
as usual i will go for the second
question first here um
what we say is that the big bang is a
moment in time that's a correct thing to
say but we should also say that big bang
didn't doesn't exist you know it's it's
a feature of classical general
relativity in a regime where classical
general relativity doesn't apply
so it's just a warning sign that says
don't believe classical general
relativity here that's all it is we
don't know what actually happened in the
real world we talk about the time since
the big bang but that's just a way of
approximating the time since space-time
became classical enough that we could
talk about such things and since we
think that that time is really really
really short
you know if the time between the actual
beginning of the universe whenever and
whatever that was
and the time when everything became
classical and well described by
classical general relativity was 10 to
the minus 30 seconds then talking about
one second after the big bang makes
perfect sense even if the big bang
itself does not okay
um so the you asked the question did the
universe have any spatial extent at all
i can answer that in the context of
classical general relativity which is
there's no such thing as the incident of
the big bang so that's a simple cop-out
what i can talk about is any time after
the big bang in classical general
relativity and then yes the universe had
a spatial extent in fact it could have
been infinite there are absolutely
solutions to einstein's equations where
space was infinite in extent arbitrarily
close to the singularity of the big bang
that's just a feature of general
relativity because it is a moment of
time after all
but then again we don't know for sure so
we don't we don't know is the short
answer um what this has to do with the
previous question is
saying the big bang is a pretty special
event
yes it is a unique event in the history
of the universe as far as we know and
certainly in the history of our
observable universe but the question
being asked is
how do we know that the universe was
taken from a random distribution so of
course we don't know that no one thinks
the universe was taken from a random
distribution people think the universe
had some particular beginning state
the
point of arguing about the past
hypothesis and the initial conditions
near the big bang is
when you see features of that initial
state
that are unusual in some coarse-grained
macroscopic human point of view sense
then maybe that is a clue to a better
understanding because after all we don't
know what happened at the big bang so as
referencing back the previous statements
about brute facts versus explanations
you can always say the big bang just
happened in a certain way or whatever
did happen at the big bang happened at a
certain way and that's it stop asking
questions right you're allowed to do
that and that might even be right
but
since we don't know what happened at the
big bang you can also say
maybe what we think of as the big bang
is a process that happens in a more
general context and there's reasons why
it looks so smooth and low entropy
and that's a natural thing to ask
because even though the big bang is a
special pretty special event as far as
we understand it it very easily could
have been otherwise there's nothing that
we know currently in our understanding
of early universe cosmology of the big
bang that would have prevented the big
bang from being highly inhomogeneous and
much higher entropy other than the fact
that it doesn't look that way right so
to me this is a very very precious clue
for theoretical cosmologists to try to
work on better understandings of what
happened at the beginning of the
universe and i don't want to give that
up
okay bruno teshera says
congratulations on the episode with
william mccaskill was one of my
favorites it was too bad you didn't you
couldn't dig into averages and
utilitarianism so i'll ask here isn't
mccaskill's ranking alternative to
scoring happiness combined with henry
siddwick's idea of maximizing number of
people times average happiness the
perfect solution to your worries about
utilitarianism
so i almost didn't
answer this question because i'm really
not familiar i'm not i couldn't even
tell you exactly what mccaskill's
ranking alternative to scoring happiness
is
or sedgwick's idea of maximizing number
of people times average happiness
so i cannot tell you that those are
perfect solutions to my worries but i
don't think that they are because my
worries aren't of that form my worries
my real worries are
not
well there's two kinds of worries right
um that one might have about any ethical
theory and that i in particular have
about utilitarianism
as a moral constructivist i think what
we mean by
our
the way that we get to moral principles
uh by meta-ethical considerations is we
start with some moral intuitions okay
there are things that we just feel are
better people should be happy they
should be nice to each other whatever
your moral intuitions are people should
play fair
people should be treated equally all
else being equal
and then we try to systematize that and
this is what we do as moral philosophers
we sit down and say okay i have these
very rough incoherent sometimes
incompatible kind of messy moral
intuitions
let's work them up into a logical system
that is
internally inc consistent in internally
consistent at the very least okay
and then put that forward
and then
the hard part starts that was the easy
part the hard part is you realize that
your system that is nice and logical and
pristine
only captures some of your moral
intuitions but then other times
conflicts with them
what do you do
and that's the situation you're in with
arguments like the repugnant conclusion
of parfit and and things like that where
basically what you're saying is i
thought that my moral intuitions when i
tried to systematize them i systematized
them into utilitarianism
but but it led me to this conclusion i
really don't like
other more naive versions of
utilitarianism will say
uh you know if you can save one person
by killing them and cutting out their
organs and distributing them to needy
people who need organs then you should
do that you're saving five lives by only
killing one right but then someone says
no no that was not my moral intuitions
at all
and so then you conclude either one of
two things
either that you don't have the right
system because you did not successfully
systematize your moral intuitions or
your one of your moral intuitions has
got to go
right and either one of those is a
perfectly legitimate move a priori
maybe you thought something was right
and then by thinking about it more
carefully you realize it wasn't that's
okay that's that's fine you're allowed
to do that
but also
you're allowed to say and you know
people like peter singer the world's
most famous utilitarian is just
the best in the world at
accepting the
implications of his system
you know as unpalable as they may be
that's not the way i generally will go
because because i am a constructivist i
want the system that i invent to do
absolutely the best it can
to systematize my actual moral
intuitions and if i find that it doesn't
i my first move is to fix the system not
to change my moral intuitions sometimes
i will but that's that's not the first
move
and so
i i that is why i object to
utilitarianism at that sort of technical
level because it does not fulfill my
moral intuitions
but there's also a different objection
that i have which and this is where i'm
more skeptical that the particular
moves that bruno is suggesting are going
to help
i just don't think it makes sense
utilitarianism i don't think that the
very idea of utility makes sense the
idea that there is some number
that we can
attack well
let's be very very careful because i
could be wrong about this and this
deserves uh to be carefully considered
not to be uh
casually dismissed
if you have any rules at all whenever
you have rules when you have a decision
procedure an algorithm or whatever
you can always after the fact
phrase that rule as maximizing some
number okay basically if i have rule
that says do a and not b
i attach the number one to the doing of
a and the number zero to the doing of b
and i say maximize that number right
it's equivalent it's just a
mathematically formal formally
equivalent way of stating your rules so
it's always possible to define something
that you maximize and call that your
moral rule even if you're the world's
biggest deontologist or virtue ethicist
but the specific feature of utility that
worries me is the idea that we just
added up among people
that the idea that somehow people have
different amounts of utility and we add
them up and that's what we maximize it's
the way of defining utility as a sum
over sub-utilities of individuals that
just seems to make no sense whatsoever
to me i don't see why that should be
true i don't see how to do it i don't
see how to compare the utilities of
different people
it just doesn't seem like a good
starting point for anything so
maybe there's some clever
kind of construal that still calls
itself utilitarianism but doesn't do
that
but i don't know about it i mean when i
say maybe i don't i don't mean that in a
sort of
um sarcastic way i mean maybe there is
such a way but i haven't seen it so i'm
not uh and i have been really very
motivated to look for it it just doesn't
seem very promising to me
i'm going to group together two
questions here
uh and again it's about morality so this
is eric speckhardt asking what exactly
do constructivists and nihilists
disagree about what denialists deny the
constructivist except
and jimmy jimi says without moral
realism how can we ever justify
intervening in other people's affairs to
impose our own morality i feel like
there needs to be a way to help people
without being hypocritical so i like
these two questions obviously they're
about similar topics but also they sort
of
if i'm reading them correctly which is
always possible that i'm not but they
seem to have
opposing implicit beliefs in them okay
which is i kind of like that because it
illustrates that the implicit beliefs
need not be universal
eric is saying you know why should
constructivist annihilus ever disagree
uh where we take nihilism to be you know
just the statement there are no moral
truths there's really no such thing as
morality anything goes
uh i'm sure a real card-carrying
nihilist would be more careful than that
but that's roughly what we have in mind
whereas a constructivist says there's no
objective
moral reality grounding moral truths out
there but we can construct our morality
and we do construct it and when we
construct it it exists and it gives us
guidance as to how to behave okay and
then different kinds of constructivists
disagree on the basis on which we do the
constructing human constructivists are
more like what i said just now where you
have your moral intuitions and you try
to systematize them there are also
kantian constructivists who try to say
that there we can just rationally think
our way into the correct constructed
rules
and so the hidden
idea there seems to be that
that
constructing step doesn't really mean
much it's just kind of a fake because i
mean the way that i stated it the
disagreement is pretty obvious like
nihilists don't think that there are
moral rules and constructivists do
and the constructivist doesn't think
that they're objective they think that
they're constructed and so the the
implication seems to be that's just
meaningless fluffery right uh and i
don't think it is i think it's just
correctly describing what real human
beings actually do and the best that
they possibly can do so what do they
disagree about they disagree about the
existence of morals and ethics which is
kind of a pretty big thing to disagree
about
whereas jimmy on the other hand is is
has basically the implicit idea that
unless
your morals are objectively grounded in
real stuff out there in the world
then they're meaningless right i mean
maybe this is the same implicit idea i'm
not quite sure
but the constructivist is going to say
yeah i have morals right here they are i
can tell you what they are i can tell
you that killing innocent babies for no
good reason is wrong that's a moral
thing i constructed it i didn't find it
by doing an experiment with electrons or
whatever but it is nevertheless a good
moral way of being and i will try to
convince other people to live in the
same way
and jimmy is saying well
how could i ever justify intervening in
other people's affairs because they
might disagree with me
well i think that's the difference
between relativism and constructivism
the relativists say individuals or
groups of individuals more typically
construct their own moral codes and
that's all there is ever to be said
morality is only relative to that
society or that community that you're a
member of that's not what
constructivists are saying they're
saying i construct moral rules and i
think that they're right
i don't think that they're objectively
right i think they're subjectively right
but i have every
justification for intervening to stop
other people from violating them why
shouldn't i so the implicit thing here
is that the only real justification for
intervening in other people's affairs is
moral realism right is that there's some
objective reason we can all agree on and
if people disagree with me i have no
right
to interfere in their affairs well well
wait a minute what do you mean you have
no right like where do these rights come
from that we're talking about here i
wasn't talking about rights if you don't
have moral realism then where is this
right supposed to be coming from i as a
moral constructivist think that
murdering innocent babies for no good
reason is wrong and if i see a person
murdering innocent babies for no good
reason i will stop them i will intervene
in their affairs i see no problem with
that i just think i'm being way more
honest and candid about where my moral
feelings come from than the moral
realist who is pretending that they're
really out there in the world
david wright says i have to ask your
take on the controversy over whether
recent jwst images show evidence that
cosmic inflation theory is mistaken how
do these images somehow contradict the
redshift data that results from an
expanding universe so they obviously
don't
the universe is expanding don't let
anyone tell you any differently
jwst is not conflicting with the
expanding universe idea now there was a
claim there is a claim that you know the
jwst remember it's one of its things is
to look at the earliest galaxies
hundreds of millions of years after the
big bang
and we're learning more about them we
have a better telescope now we're seeing
galaxies younger than we used to see
okay
and the claim is that we are seeing
galaxies even though they're just a
couple pixels in size they are too young
and too compact and well-formed to be
what is predicted by the conventional
cosmological model they're forming too
early so
of course it may be that we don't know a
lot about galaxy formation right this is
exactly the kind of thing that is
involving a lot more ideas than just the
basic idea of the big bang theory in the
expanding universe
forming a galaxy is kind of a mess it is
exactly the kind of complex system
gastrophysically intimidating problem
that we poor human beings are not very
good at solving so if you find
data that is not an immediate fit to
your current best theory of galaxy
formation you don't throw out the big
bang you throw out your current best
theory of galaxy formation or you even
maybe probably just update it a little
bit i don't know how easy it is to
update it
but there's absolutely zero reason in
anything that the james webb has seen or
anything else to doubt the basic big
bang model of the universe expanding
from an initial hot dense state now
cosmic inflation theory is not part of
the standard big bang model it's an
addition to it that says what happened
in the first 10 to the minus 30th of a
second right and that may or may not be
true that's much less settled than the
big bang theory overall
and maybe
the inflation theory makes specific
predictions that are hard to accommodate
with the galaxy data i think that's not
true by the way but it is a conceivable
thing that could be true once we
understand both the theory and the data
better but nothing you know the the data
for the broad parameters of what we call
the big bang model not the big bang
event right which is this mysterious
thing that didn't happen uh that is just
the place where classical general
relativity breaks down but the big bang
model is what cosmologists use to refer
to the whole general story
of a used a universe expanding and
cooling from an initially hot dense
state that is just true that is just
solid i mean you should always be a good
bayesian and have a tiny credence in
alternatives but as i've said before
you should you know there reaches a
point where your credence is so small
that it's not worth worrying about and
this is such an example big bang nuclear
synthesis the cosmic microwave
background structure formation the very
basic predictions of general relativity
all offer overwhelming evidence in the
basic big bang model
dushan stolianovic says
here is the gist of an often made
argument which i think is flawed and
which you've also used on occasion most
recently in the july ama
several of the most recent presidential
elections would have gone democrat had
the competition been for the popular
vote instead of for the electoral
college
in my opinion better political campaigns
are ones that are responsible for close
election victories and thus the better
of the campaigns would have just
campaigned differently had the popular
vote been the goal saying that donald
trump won the electoral vote but hillary
clinton won the popular vote is akin to
saying that team a won the basketball
game against team b on points but team b
won on rebounds the definition of the
verb to win assumes the existence of a
particular competition or contest please
comment
so a couple of uh nitpicky comments
first before getting to the the bigger
picture you know you say the quote is
several of the most recent presidential
elections would have gone democrat dot
dot dot which you call an often made
argument but it's not an argument
that was their argument there that's
just a statement uh i mean it's a
hypothetical statement which could be
true or false but presumably one has in
mind some argument for the truth or
falsity of that statement and that would
be the actual argument
the second nitpicky thing is the
basketball game analogy
sure
the no one is at least i'm not denying
that donald trump did win the election
against hillary clinton the the claim
that
if it had been a popular vote rather
than the electoral college clinton would
have won
is not the same saying that she did win
just on some weird thing right trump won
the election that that's perfectly uh
unassailable the purported claim is that
under a different electoral system the
ter the uh outcome would have been
different and i think that's entirely
plausible you know i think that politics
is more than just who had the best
political team the argument here is not
about whose political team was doing
better it is how best to coarse grain
the will of the people into choosing its
representation and
it may very well be possible that donald
trump's political team was just so savvy
that had the goal been to win the
popular vote instead of the electoral
vote he would have done that too
i see zero evidence for that claim i see
no reason to think that it's true and
also it's not the point the point is
i don't think that the current electoral
college is the best way of aggregating
the will of the people into picking a
winner
if it had been the case that we had a
system where it was the popular vote
that chose the president and
donald trump's political team was just
so smart they would have won in that
condition also then good for them i
still think it would be the better thing
my goal here is not to change the rules
so that clinton wins the game my goal
here is to get the best political system
to pick our representatives and the
reason why we have the electoral college
in its current form are very antiquated
reasons that just don't apply anymore
even if they were good to start which
probably they weren't so i think there's
more important things you can do to fix
the political system than have the
popular vote for the presidency but i do
think it would be one step forward
igor velotic says what do you think
about david deutsch's criticism of
bayesianism as a philosophy of science
or epistemology with some examples like
that
when an experiment refutes a highly
believed theory you don't know if the
credence for the theory or for the
quality of an experiment should go down
or the conjunction t1 and t2 of two
mutually inconsistent explanatory
theories t1 and t2 such as quantum
theory and relativity is provably false
and therefore a zero probability yet it
embodies some understanding of the world
and is definitely better than nothing as
opposed to that what he thinks that what
scientists science really seeks to
maximize is explanatory power
and that although all our best theories
of fundamental physics are going to be
superseded eventually and therefore we
believe they're negations it is still
those false theories not their true
negations that constitute all of our
deepest knowledge of physics
so i'm not an expert on deutsche's
criticisms of bayesianism so whatever i
say here should not be taken as a
refutation of david deutsch because i'm
re reading igor's question not david's
uh statements about these things but i
can explain to you how a good bayesian
would deal with the situations which you
mentioned which are perfectly legitimate
situations to worry about uh you know so
there's two different examples here one
is
experiment refutes a highly believed
theory so let's make it specific someone
claims they have measured the travel
velocity of some neutrinos and they go
faster than the speed of light okay so
you have a
an experimental result neutrinos going
faster than light and you have a highly
believed theory special relativity and
the idea in the standard model that
neutrinos do not go faster than the
speed of light so what you say is
you don't know if credence for the
theory or for the quality of an
experiment should go down
well i think it's both i mean i think
you just take these seriously with all
the different possibilities on the table
uh it's not that we have to
look at them separately they're coupled
to each other in interesting ways so we
have the credence that the theory is
wrong we have the credence that the
experiment is wrong we have the the
queens that both of them are wrong or
that we're missing something entirely
and we're allowed to take all of our
information and our other priors into
consideration if the prior for our
theory is really really good and our
prior that these experimenters could
have made a mistake is non-trivially
large
then the credence that we have in our
theory is not going to change very much
on the basis of that experiment you just
run through the mat he's run through the
equations and you find in that situation
that you end up believing it's probably
true that the experiment was a mistake
and then you can go up and get more data
with more experiments as you always do
in science so i don't see this as an any
kind of critique of bayesianism at all
the other example
when you have two mutually inconsistent
explanatory theories like quantum theory
and relativity and i imagine what you
mean is general relativity einstein's
theory of gravity so
the point is you know that these
theories both can't be right and
therefore have zero probability but they
do embody some understanding of the
world
i think that's just missing what the
theories are i think that theories have
domains of applicability right neither
um quantum mechanics as we currently
understand it nor general relativity
especially general relativity are
purported to be true in every domain
right
quantum mechanics might be it has a
chance of being at least but general
relativity certainly not so
when you say general relativity is true
it cap that that's i would agree that it
captures something true about nature in
a certain limit right
and quantum mechanics also captures
something true about nature they can't
both be extended to fully comprehensive
theories of nature at the same time
right that i agree with but who cares no
one ever thought they should be general
relativity is a classical theory there's
no more claim that it needs to be
extended to every domain of of
explanation any more than any other
classical theory it's supposed to be
true in the classical limit so there's
there's no problem for a good bayesian
in saying both that general relativity
does a really good job of fitting the
data in its domain of applicability and
that quantum mechanics does a really
good job of fitting
the experiments in its domain of
applicability so there i don't even know
what the worry is supposed to be
honestly it's just once again i think
that not really thinking carefully
enough about what you think those the
the
labels t1 and t2 are really supposed to
refer to
rue phillips says this is the last
question we're ending up for the day
thanks for your indulgence here once
again
rue says how do you navigate
interactions with professional
colleagues that strongly disagree with
the science you focus on for example
sabina hassenfelder is someone you
respect as a physicist and yet she calls
people that do many worlds science
confused
do you avoid interacting with credible
professional scientists that can be
somewhat hostile toward people like you
and string theorists or do you just
avoid the topic when you chat or
something else i'm curious about the
interpersonal dynamics here
well you know i think this is a very
good question that's why i picked it for
the last question here it's a i think
that there is
there could be better understanding of
how scientists
or academics more generally doesn't need
to be scientists uh interact with each
other because two things are
simultaneously true one is there are
plenty of academics who are just jerks
who are just bad people and it's
unpleasant to interact with them uh i'm
not this is not sabine i'm talking about
but there exists out there in the world
of academia people who are unpleasant
again not very surprising i mean
academics are people just like everybody
else right
and uh so you deal with them the same
way you deal with other people and you
just try to avoid them you the best you
can i mean i'm someone who believes
probably more stronger than average
that obnoxious people are not worth
having around even if they're brilliant
right like if you say if you're trying
to hire someone as a postdoc or faculty
member or whatever and you say well
they're really a terrible person and i
don't want to talk with them but they're
really brilliant and do good work
i don't want to work with that person i
don't want to hire that person like
there's other brilliant people there who
are not unpleasant to talk to so i would
like to hire those people and hang out
with them
um
but the more interesting question is
what about people who are
not obnoxious or not not intrinsically
obnoxious like we can all be obnoxious
sometimes that's why i'm hesitating like
there's no such thing as a completely
non-obnoxious person maybe there is
uh but most people have moments right
before and against but what i'm thinking
of is people who are basically good
people and easy to talk to but who
strongly disagree with you about
something that's the interesting case uh
to interact with and i think you know
it's i would like to understand this
better even though i've been
immersed in it for decades for for much
of my life
i think academics
do pretty well
at
being friends and interacting and yet
disagreeing really strongly about things
um
it's kind of a weird thing i mean you
can you can get out of control and
that's why i'm i'm talking slowly and
hesitating here because i can think of
examples where people have taken the
paradigm too far but roughly speaking
i i have seen people including and i
could be on one side of this interaction
myself i could see people in seminars or
in discussions over coffee saying like
oh my god you're completely insane
you've completely lost the plot that is
an idiotic thing to say like how dare
you like what happened to you you used
to be smarter than that right and at the
end then you go out and have fun at
dinner or take have a beer or whatever
right
because it's about the material it's
about the subject matter it's not a
personal attack
it can become personal and this is what
i'm sort of getting at that it can slip
into overly personal attacks and that's
bad there are absolutely examples where
two people who used to be friends have
come to disagree about something
scientific and the friendship has
deteriorated because of that and that's
too bad so i want to acknowledge two
things simultaneously one is that
scientists are people
and they can get out of control both in
being a little thoughtless and in
reacting against that thoughtlessness
and
there is a possibility that is often a
reality of strong strong disagreements
that do not become personal or
unfriendly and so that should happen
more often than it does uh but it does
happen um
some of my best friends i think are just
completely crazy pants when it comes to
certain of their scientific beliefs and
you know and we joke about it like
they'll say like oh yeah you know i'm a
bowmanian and i actually say ah oh my
goodness what i didn't know like you
you've kept that dirty laundry hidden
for so long how could you do that how
could you say this to me
but
it's a it's a joke because it's not
personal it doesn't insult me right we
don't know the final answers to a lot of
these questions
um you know like carlo revelli who is a
friend of mine has on more than one
occasion in more than one context said
like how can you be so smart and yet
believe the string theory is still
reasonable
or you know pretty good for a string
theorist kind of thing and by the way
i'm not a string theorist i just think
that it is for good reason the most
promising root quantum gravity we have
on the table right now but anyway uh
these are things that i think are just
part of being a good academic it's this
is part of being a good intellectual a
good scholar separating out uh your
opinions your credences on questions of
substance from your personal opinions
about other people and their opinions
and part of it is you can't help but
know people who you respect otherwise
who have some crazy ideas in their heads
that's just how life is so
anyway i think i don't know whether
that's a very
helpful answer to the question but i
think that there are both things going
on you know people getting a little too
touchy a little too personal attacky
sometimes but a pretty remarkable
ability to
have cordial respectful relations
without getting that personal sometimes
i think that's crucial to being an
academic and i think that more people
outside of academia should develop that
capacity anyway
thanks for listening thanks for
supporting mindscape and thanks for
listening to another ama uh great
gratitude always goes out from me to all
of you who support mindscape by being
patrons and any of you who listen to it
for any reason whatsoever i hope that it
gives you something to think about
and maybe sparks an idea here or there
bye bye
[Music]
you